commention je pense que d'autres
collègues vont nous rejoindre dans les
instants mais dans les instants qui
suivent mais pour ne pas prendre trop de
retard nous allons débuter de notre
réunion de ce matin qui est une réunion
importante consacrée au secteur de de la
recherche et nous avons à cette occasion
le plaisir d'accueillir Bruno Bonnel qui
est secrétaire général pour
l'investissement chargé de France 2030
un plan qui est important du point de
vue de la programmation financière
euh
publ antoine Petit qui est président
directeur général du CNRS que nous avons
l'habitude d'auditionner dans cette
commission et puis le professeur Samuel
qui est président- directeur général de
lgerme nous avions auditionné l'année
dernière au moment de de de sa
candidature messieurs votre présence
conjointe nous offre l'occasion
d'aborder avec vous l'articulation de
France 2030 avec la politique publique
de recherche en particulier le le
déploiement de la LPR la loi de
programmation de la recherche dont nous
attendons la la revoyure et l'impact de
ce plan pour les organismes nationaux de
recherche comme le le CNRS et et linerm
Monsieur Bonnel
pourriez-vous tout d'abord nous dresser
un état des lieux de France 2030 je
rappelle que celui-ci prévoit de
mobiliser 54 milliards d'euros autour de
de trois axes couvrant toutes les phases
de l'innovation de la recherche
fondamentale à l'industrialisation le
premier AX mieux produire en faisant
émerger des petits réacteurs nucléaires
modulaires dit SMR et en faisant de de
la France le le leader de l'hydrogène
vert et en décarbonant no notre
industrie le deuxème mieux vivre en
favorisant une alimentation saine
durable et traçable en produisant 20
biomédicaments notamment contre les
cancers et les maladies chroniques et en
créant les dispositifs médicaux de
demain et le trisème enfin mieux
comprendre en investissant dans la
nouvelle aventure spatiale et dans le
champ des fonds marins de de grande
profendeur
monsieurtit petit et Samuel
pourriez-vous ensuite nous dire comment
les organismes de recherche que que vous
dirigez sont impliqués dans la mise en
œuvre de de ce plan et quelles en sont
pour eux les les les premières
répercussions plus globalement
estimez-vous que la recherche française
sortira renforcée de France 2030 après
vos interventions respectives notre
rapporteur sur les crédits consacrés à
la recherche Laurence Garnier vous
posera une première série de questions
et puis ensuite bien sûr chacune des
sénatrices et chacun des sénateurs qui
souhaitera s'exprimer pourra le faire
dans un esprit bien sûr de de dialogue
avant de céder la parole au secrétaire
général pour l'investice pour le France
2030 je rappelle à chacun d'entre vous
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et
consultable ensuite en vidéo à la
demande monsieur le Secrétaire général
je vais vous laisser la
parole merci monsieur le président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
tout d'abord permettez-moi de vous
souhaiter les meilleurs vœux pour cette
année il est encore
temps et vous dire que nous sommes ravis
de vous présenter cette ce volet là de
de France 2030 un un
petit un petit tour de PIST déjà de de
ce qu'est France 2030 et où on en est je
pense que ça rentre dans un
contexte plus global France 2030
finalement c'est
sont président de la République il y a 2
ans qui en réponse au défi euh de notre
de notre siècle les défis énergétiques
les défi évidemment climatique mais
également les défis démographique qui
commence à se faire criant euh à a
décidé que nous allions aller vers
l'innovation non pas pour être des
technosolutionnistes mais simplement
parce qu'elle est un outil de réflexion
qui montre comment la résilience
comment l'intelligence et et le génie
l'imagination peuvent effectivement
faire du progrès un outil de réponse à
ces grandes difficultés et non pas
simplement être
obsédé par une croissance pour la
croissance une espèce de société du plus
non pas être désespéré résigné en
croyant que la solution c'est une
société du moins par la décroissance
mais tout simplement avoir la conviction
que c'est la société du mieux qui est
certainement celle qui doit être
construite à travers ces innovations
alors pour rendre ça tangible et pas
théorique il a été décidé de donner à à
nos concitoyens un cap au travers
d'objets très très concrets comme par
exemple fabriquer à 2030 2 millions de
véhicules électrique comme par exemple
réussir à lancer une une fusée dans
l'espace ou fabriquer des biomédicament
c'est utiliser la biologie plutôt que la
chimie pour pour
soigner si j'insiste sur cet aspect là
c'est pour dire que ce c'est ce ne sont
pas des des moyens financiers
considérables 54 milliards qui sont
simplement jeté comme ça en pâure en
fonction des alli et opportunités mais
il y a bien la construction d'un système
d'un système de recherche un système de
de de développement de recherche
appliquée d'un système de de premières
usines pour véritablement faire passer
la France dans d'un d'un d'une société
que je qualifieraai de chenis fossile à
une société de papillon électrique
c'est-à-dire que une révolution à la
fois énergétique mais également une
révolution sociétale dans laquelle
effectivement nous devons nous l'état
contribuer en dérisquant à différents
niveaux à différents étages de la
réflexion en dérisquant l'audace que
pourrait avoir nos chercheurs nos
entrepreneurs nos industriels j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus parce que la question
a pourrait être posée de de se dire
finalement quel est le rôle de l'État si
on réfléchissait simplement en terme de
marché en terme de ouvrir les guillemets
tri retour sur investissement en fait le
rôle de l'État il est véritablement là
en terme de retour sur l'impact que ça
peut avoir dans notre quotidien
effectivement un impact qu'on commence à
voir de façon j'allais dire embryonnaire
dans sememble de secteurs on s'aperçoit
notamment que le développement par de la
voiture électrique est une réalité une
réalité et et que toute notre industrie
automobile demain va se convertir
progressivement sur peut-être une sur
peut-être deux générations va se
convertir totalement dans des nouveaues
manières de de des n des nouvelles
énergies et là le rôle de l'État il est
vraiment de dire aux industriels et aux
chercheurs allez-y n'hésitez pas nous
sommes là pour essayer de vous aider de
vous accompagner d'accélérer finalement
votre réflexion alors maintenant je vais
rentrer la focale sur le sujet qui nous
intéresse mais je voulais quand même
vous expliquer que c'était dans un
contexte qui n'est pas simplement de
dire tient un peu à l'instar de d'autres
pays du monde qui choisissent des axes
de recherche par exemple et qui disent
bah nous on va rester sur tel axe et le
reste ben tant pis alors le la réflexion
qui peut être faite c'est dire est-ce
que vous avez prenez pas le risque de
vous justement disperser et en fait
c'est exactement l'inverse nous nous
nous avons un objectif c'est l'évolution
de la société dans sa dans sa globalité
et on voit bien qu'il y a énormément de
systèmes qui s'enrichissent les uns les
autres que les Américains appellent la
Seren pti ce que moi j'aime bien appeler
l'enrichissement c'estàd que la
recherche spatiale va servir à au
biomédicament le biomédicament lui va
servir peut-être à des évolutions sur
des recherches en santé en alimentation
par exemple et cetera et cetera alors
dans ce contexte là et en j'allais
presque dire en parallèle de ça parce
que comme d tout à l'heure c'est un
c'est un exercice systémique de
transformation de société il y a eu la
réflexion sur le nouveau le nouveau rôle
des des onr en tant que ouvrez les
guillemets agence de programme et
comment est-ce que nous on participe à
ça je laisserai
évidemment les les les présidents des
différents honnaurs qui sont là pour
pour vous pour vous expliquer l'interne
mais nous l'articulation avec France
2030 elle est elle se passe en trois
phases il y a un premier étage de fusée
qui s'appelle les PEPR autrement dit les
programmes et équipements prioritaires
de recherche alors eux c'est ce sont des
des des des domaines prioritaires qui
sont sélectionnés et sur lesquels on
donne des moyens pour qu'il se qu'il se
développe on est au au cœur de la du
déploiement nous sommes maintenant à 2
ans du déploiement de France 2030
globalement d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de
donner ce chiffre sur les 54 milliards
30 milliards ont été engagés hein donc
nous sommes vraiment j'allais dire à la
2uxème mi-temps on commence la 2è
mi-temps même un peu plus en ce qui
concerne les PEPR c'est doté d'un budget
de 3,3 milliards d'euros dont dont deux
milliards sont intégré au stratégie
nationale d'accélération et 1,3
milliards sont dédiés à des programmes
qu'on appelle exploratoirees c'est le
premier étage de la
fusée on va dire recherche fondamentale
et et donc les ces fameux PPR le deuxème
étage de la
fusée se subdivise en en trois actions
simultanées de l'État euh qu'on regroupe
sous le terme recherche à risque le
premièrement c'est les les suite à la à
la mission de de Monsieur Philippe gilet
qui a été confié par le le ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche il y a eu une définition de
création des agences de programme au
sein de de cinq organismes nationaux
donc le CNRS le CEA l'in Rae line rya et
lin sererme alors
l'enjeu de ces futurs agence et et
d'aider à construire sur des domaines
spécifiques la vision Pr obective de
l'État la mission a été a remis ses
conclusions juste au printemps dernier
donc j'allais dire ça ça sort un petit
peu du four nous sommes dans la
dynamique de de de création
euh donc 2è étage de notre de pardon 2e
segment de notre notre 2e étage c'est la
répartition de ces fameux PEPR dont je
viens de vous parler donc ces programmes
de recherche entre les différents onr
avec une logique de qu'on peut qualifier
de pilote unique
cette répartition elle est thématique
alors je peux je peux vous en donner un
un les thèmes je dirais à à coûp de
hache donc l'incerme c'est la santé
l'inrae c'est agriculture alimentation
durable forêt et ressources naturel
associé le CNRS c'est climat
biodiversité et société au pluriel
durable donc une réflexion plus plus
globale le CEA énergie décarbonée d'une
part et T ce que ce que j'allais dire du
composant au système et tout ce qui est
infrastructure numérique d'autre part
l'ineria c'est le numérique et le
logiciel et bien
évidemment on on peut rajouter le cè
parce que c'est une une nouvelle
frontière de réflexion sur le le spatial
vous voyez ces thématiques sont à la
fois précise mais sont des axes
suffisamment larges pour que les briques
technologiques qui soit associé soit
soit quand même assez assez ouverte
alors la troisème composante de ce
deuxème étage c'est l'action recherche à
risque donc ça c'est elle est assez
spécifique qui a été lancée par France
2030 qui est financée par force France
2030 nous avons envoyé aux différents
organismes une lettre de cadrage sur sur
l'idée je reviens sur ce mot audace je
pourrais utiliser le mot dans la
recherche de prospective en tout cas de
chercher à être un petit peu un
avant-coureur et de pas euh se limiter à
à de la répétition mais au contraire
essayer d'explorer des des nouvell voie
euh ça nous semble critique et
euh l'idée euh avec ce ce programme
recherche à risque qui est doté de 500
millions d'euros euh c'est véritablement
euh euh de de soutenir de façon euh euh
volontariste de façon euh déterminée
mais surtout rapide euh des recherches
et des innovations euh de frontières
euh et de et et véritablement un peu de
et transformatrice alors pour tout cela
et j'en terminerai par là euh nous
sommes dans une année de
d'expérimentation hein de ces euh de ces
agences euh enfin en lien avec ces
agences de création de de
programmes le la gouvernance de France
2030 que qui est euh euh qui est euh
piloté par un par un Comex un comité
exécutif qui regroupe l'ensemble des
administrations euh enfin qui est
interministériel dans administration de
différents ministères s'est réuni le le
28 novembre 2023 donc c'est c'est récent
et euh on a lancé une phase
d'expérimentation de de 150 millions
d'euros euh dans une première année de
mise en œuvre donc nous sommes nous
attaquons si je peux me permettre on est
vraiment dans au à l'actualité brûlante
en présentant devant cette commission et
euh au terme bah de cette année on fera
on fera un point d'étape et
effectivement si si tout correspond à
nos objectifs on on avancera alors je je
terminerai par une remarque plus
de plus
d'observation la dynamique de France
2030 est une dynamique
interministérielle je vous l'ai dit
notre gouvernance est est sous un Comex
d'administration centrale qui regroupe
tous les
ministères il est clair que avec cette
création des des organismes nationaux de
recherche il il y aura certainement une
évolution
sérieuse de de l'interface de ces
organismes avec l'État qui se fera
probablement de façon plus
interministériel encore et moi ce que je
peux vous dire en témoin de cette en
témoin de de notre activité au niveau de
France 2030 ça ça enrichi énormément le
débat à savoir que le fait que nous
ayons des des angles de vue différente
sur certaines problématiques
d'innovation chez France 2030 nous nous
permet justement de de ne pas être dans
un un si je pouis utiliser le mot dans
un dogmatique ou dans une
rigidité
qui qui pourrait être un seul axe d'un
seul ministère donc voilà je je voulais
préciser ça je crois qu'il y a une il y
a une une agilité une efficacité et un
bénéfice certain à pouvoir justement
travailler avec différents différents
organismes et différents ministères de
l'État pour lui pour leur donner une
pour leur pour être pour être le plus
finalement en phase et le moins hors sol
possible dans la réflexion de recherche
même si elle elle est elle vise plutôt
les étoiles comme je vous l'ai expliquer
voilà voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire
en synthèse maintenant on va je
répondrai évidemment à T V questions
mais mais surtout c'est Didier Samuel et
Antoine petit qui à mon avis pourraont
être beaucoup plus précis merci merci je
ne sais pas qui commence entre Samuel en
petit
[Musique]
merci donc merci monsieur le Président
donc en effet
euh euh France 2030 est pour nous de
même que la loi de programmation de la
recherche on y reviendra mais France
2030 est pour nous en effet une occasion
importante
de de booster la recherche en santé et
donc c'est comme ça que je le vois
puisque d'abord au sein de France 2030
il y a un volet santé et donc qui a
identifié pour nous c'est important ce
volet santé a permis en effet de
financer des des programmes comme l'a
dit Bruno Bonnel des programme
importants que que sont les PEPR et
l'Inserm notamment pilote ou copilote h
programmes
8 PEPR et donc c'est C c'est clairement
un investissement majeur en recherche
c'est aussi une autre façon de
travailler euh parce que en effet c'est
par rapport je dirais à à l'habitude de
de je dirais des des appels d'offres en
recherche qui sont habituellement
ouverts les PEPR sont aussi une façon
différente de travailler avec plus de
topd et donc des on peut dire presque à
50 % 50 % selon les PEPR parfois plus
des programmes fléchés et donc
l'organisation donc avec la mise en en
commun de consortium scientifies de
consortium de chercheurs scientifiques
autour de projets qui sont je dirais
ciblé par un collège d'experts dans le
domaine ce qui fait que on rejoint ici
une interrogation qui avait été
d'ailleurs quand je suis arrivé qui
avait été évoqué par la Cour des comptes
fait-on asszette stratégie et a-on assez
de stratégies scientifiqu et en effet
les PEPR et puis diverses actions France
2030 permettent en effet d'insérer la
stratégie et donc c'est alors le le
point positif je le dis tout de suite
c'est en effet que c'est un
investissement important euh c'est 8
PEPR euh on a certains PEPR
exploratoires qui n'ont pas été choisis
on et ça c'est ça fait partie du jury ça
fait partie de la vie de la la recherche
mais aussi on a des je veux dire des PPR
qui s'intéresse à des sujets majeurs
biothérapie bioproduction pour nous
numérique en santé euh santé des femmes
un peu perd à 30 million d'euros où il y
a deux axes qui sont très actuels
puisqu'on en discute beaucoup qui sont
infertilité endométriose qui sont des
axes de recherche euh maladie
infectieuse émergente donc dans une
atmosphère
postcovid et puis donc d'autres d'autres
programmes qui sont aussi alimentation
microbiote et santé donc tout ça sont
des programmes qui sont importants et
aussi qui nous permettent de faire de la
stratégie et qui permettent aussi de de
mettre en commun des des collectifs de
chercheurs et donc c'est une façon
différente de travailler et qui que les
chercheurs ont doivent aussi
s'approprier et aussi que les instances
comme l'inserve des organismes comme
l'inser doivent s'approprier ce qui a
été fait le seul petit bémol et si je
peux quand même l'exprimer c'est je
dirais que la mise en route des
PPR aurait pu être plus rapide et c'est
je pense qu'on peut et je pense que si
on fait une analyse c'est c'est mon avis
si on fait une analyse je pense qu'on
peut dans une deuxème phase dans la
réflexion essayer de simplifier et de je
dirais de raccourcir certains
aller-retours entre les différents
partenaires onr ANR SGPI et je pense que
c'est un travail personnellement que je
souhaite c'est-à-dire essayer de
simplifier les procédures maintenant
qu'on commence à les connaître pour je
dirais raccourcir les délais entre la
décision du programme et son engagement
c'est c'est je dirais le le le point qui
qui me paraît important à corriger pour
le reste c'est un élément très positif
et d'autre part dans France 2030 en
dehors des pr des PEPR il y a des
actions aussi qui sont importantes que
il y a un soutien au programme bioban
que nous coordonnons et les bioban c'est
en recherche en santé c'est euh c'est
absolument
indispensable on on peut même je dirais
souhaiter que il y a un renforcement de
ce côté-là parce que ça implique aussi
euh beaucoup de partenaires et les
hôpitaux notamment pour qu'il collectent
euh je dirais les les les les produits
euh des patients et euh pouvoir aussi
les utiliser un programme de soutien au
cort qui sont euh qui a un élément a
donc un programme francecoortte et puis
euh je vais parler d'autres programmes
mais euh derrière euh euh et puis le
comme l'a évoqué euh euh Bruno Bonnel le
programme euh recherche à risque euh
pour lequel euh l'incerme devrait
recevoir euh 30 millions d'euros qui est
en effet euh je pense que pour l'incerme
et moi je le vois comme ça c'est comment
dire euh c'est peut-être une analyse en
tout cas je dirais en santé une analyse
à postériori de ce qui s'est passé
pendant le covid en disant par exemple
est-ce que la France était prête
complètement sur les technologies RN
messager la réponse est probablement non
et donc on peut mais qui aurait pu aussi
prévoir que les technologies de la RN il
y a 20 ans ceux qui travaillaient sur
l'ARN messager l'ARN il y a 20 ans ça
allait ça allait par exemple dépasser la
thérapie génique parce que et ça c'est
des c'est des éléments euh sur lesquels
on doit s'interroger il y a 20 ans on
parlait que de thérapie génique et des
thérapie ADN et en fait on s'aperçoit
que on a maintenant des médicaments à
base d'aéren avec des ce qu'on appelle
les aérennes interférents des laarn
messager qui a été utilisé dans les
vaccins et avec maintenant aussi des
travaux sur des vaccins antiancer à
partir de l'è messager et ça ça avait
pas été envisagé probablement ou que CER
ou par uniquement certains il y a il y a
20 ans ou 25 ans quand ces technologies
ont commen à émerger mais aussi a une
rencontre avec l'amélioration des
technologies avec des techniques aussi
de de ciseaux moléculaires des qui qui
n'existait pas aussi et donc c'est la
rencontre entre l'amélioration des des
des techniques les découvertes
scientifique et puis aussi une une
expérience donc recherche à risque c'est
aussi un programme dont l'incerme et les
autres organismes vont s'emparé qui va
démarrer en 2024 donc ça c'est je dirais
les points importants et puis dans dans
France santé 2030 on espère aussi et on
va je vais parler aussi de l'agence de
programme on espère aussi qu'il y ait
d'autres programmes que nous soumettrons
via l'agence mais aussi que aussi que
que l'État pourra nous confier et et
j'ai en tête en effet un programme
France vaccin qui me paraît extrêmement
important parce qu'en effet je pense
qu'on doit se coordonner coordonner
l'ensemble des acteurs pour autour de de
de de ce programme et
donc donc enfin dans France 2030 il y a
eu des des objets qui sont pour la santé
les IHU puisqueil y a eu une vague
récente de 12 labellisations d'ihu dans
lequel l'inserme est complètement
appliqué et d'ailleurs la première vague
d'ihu va être expertisée par l' CHS à la
fin de l'année et mais et on sait qu'il
y a des IHU qui marchent très bien
d'autres qui marchent moins bien mais
enfin les IHU sont aussi des pour
l'incerme qui est fondateur de tous les
IHU c'est aussi un objet d'excellence et
euh et les IHU il y a aussi les pour la
santé secteur de la santé dans le cadre
de France 2030 les les biocluster il y a
cinq bioclusters et comme vous le savez
l'un des points donc cinq bioclusters en
deux vagues le premier le pscc le Paris
saint-clay Cancer Campus qui est le
premier qui a démarré sur le cancer et
qui
associe Gustave rousi Sanofi donc un
industriel mais aussi l'Institut
polytechnique l'Université Paris sa-clay
et l'inserme comme membre fondateur et
qui est qui qui est en train vraiment
d'être lancé et puis quatre autres
bioclusters qui sont en train d'arriver
sur un Marseille sur l'immunologie un
lion sur l'infectiologie euh et puis
deux autres sur Paris géotaire et et
brain and mine sur le cerveau et sur
aussi la génétique donc ces bioclusters
aussi visent aussi à euh sont à
l'interface santé et monde industriel et
ces biocusters aussi visent à essayer de
de combler un gap euh en France qui est
que on a on peut dire qu'on a une
recherche académique de qualité euh
compétitive en tout cas dans certains
domaines au au niveau international et
parfois leader mais qu'on a une déficite
en valorisation de notre recherche
académique à la et en santé la
production de médicaments euh je dirais
français euh sur des découvertes
françaises et donc ça c'est et donc les
bioclusters visent aussi à à à à essayer
de réduire ce gap et c'est aussi euh
l'occasion aussi d'arriver à à améliorer
le le le je dirais le le partenariat et
les relations entre le monde académique
et le monde industriel parce que de
toute façon en santé on peut pas la
recherche seule ça suffit pas il faut
savoir faire des médicaments et les
chercheurs ne sont pas ne savent pas
fabriquer des médicaments et c'est pas
leur métier et donc il faut de toute
façon discuter et travailler avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique en respectant
bien sûr les règles donc pour France
2030 c'est c'est clairement un plus et
pour et en et en l'occurrence aussi pour
l'incerme le point important et que j'ai
souligné c'est qu'il y a un volet santé
et que ce volet santé c'est aussi pour
moi remettre l'importance de la
recherche biomédicale au cœur du paysage
et pour la France je pense que c'est une
conclusion qui a été faite en post covid
je pense que et c'est aussi un enjeu
pour la France de souveraineté nationale
mais c'est aussi un enjeu pour la
qualité de la médecine française d'être
avoir une recherche médicale compétitive
c'est aussi avoir une recherche une
santé compétitive al l'autre aspect
c'est les c'est l'agence de programme et
je sais pas si donc si donc qu' a évoqué
Bruno Bonnel et donc sur les agences de
programme donc moi je me félicite que on
confie à l'inerme l'agence de programme
recherche en santé je pense que c'est
une clarification du paysage ça a deux
de deux grandes implications
premièrement pour moi ça ne remet pas en
cause le notre activité de d'opérateur
de recherche et qu'on doit développer
renforcer c'estàd on doit d'un côté
renforcer via nos unités mixtes de
recherche avec les universités notre
force de frappe en recherche et être
plus visible au National international
et donc renforcer notre masse critique
être aussi améliorer la stratégie et et
plus stratégique en terme de de de choix
donc ça c'est le premier point et
l'autre point c'est en effet la mise en
route d'une agence de programme qui à la
fois doit être pluripartenaire donc
coordonné par l'inser mais je le vois à
la fois comme le rôle de l'inserme étant
celui d'un coordonnateur
euh permettant aussi avec l'avantage
d'embarquer je dirais dans dans cette
agence l'ensemble du bloc recherche
chanté et ça c'est nouveau et c'est ce
que j'essaie d'expliquer à l'ensemble
des partenaires hôpitaux compris CHU
centre de lutte contre le cancer
c'està-dire avoir et finalement ça va
permettre dans cette agence aux
différents partenaires de se parler et
de et pas seulement bilatéral mais en
avec l'ensemble des partenaires les
universités les autres organismes les
hôpitaux universitaires notamment et
bien sûr l'incerme et donc c'est euh et
ça nécessite par contre d'avoir une
gouvernance qui est partagée mais aussi
on on doit être efficient et ça il y a
c'est c'est un vrai travail que l'on met
en place c'est-à-dire il y a beaucoup de
gens autour de la table il faut qu'on
arrive à une efficience et et à être
effectif en terme de de choix et pas
être bloquant et ça c'est essentiel et
c'est un des des objectifs de cette
première année de de de mise route de
l'agence et aussi rassurer les les
partenaires sur le fait que l'inserme a
à la fois son rôle d'opérateur de
recherche ses unités de recherche avec
les université mais le rôle de l'agence
aussi sera une gouvernance qui sera à la
fois au sein de l'incerme mais à la fois
indépendante ou autonome et avec je
dirais une pour rassurer les partenaires
sur le fait que les programmes seront et
le financement sera partagé ce qu'on
sait déjà faire sur différents
programmes comme le plan cancer ou les
ou même les les programmes en maladie
infectieuse émergente via la NRS qui est
je le rappelle une agence de l'inserme
et en fait c'est c'est le challenge pour
nous de de de de cette année qui a donc
un un challenge essentiel et
actuellement donc je une partie de mon
travail est de mettre en route l'agence
pour qu'elle et sa première réunion je
dirais mi-février d'ici mi-février donc
et puis je pense en effet qu'on aura
quelques sousbrosau c'est une première
année on fera une évaluation au bout
d'un an mais les grandes lignes c'est
premièr clarification du paysage de la
recherche en santé et on confie à
l'incerme le rôle de coordination et
bien sûr l'inserme confiera aussi enfin
cette agence confiera le pilotage de de
certains programmes au CNRS au CEA quand
ce sera plus leur thématique ou un
collectif de Chu ou un collectif
d'université donc ça on va l'organiser
mais mon mon rôle aussi c'est
d'organiser aussi une une agence qui
marche qui soit efficiente qui propose
des programmes qui soche priorisés qui
soit en en dialogue auss avec l'État sur
un ce que veut l'État et nous ce qu' ce
qu'on souhaite comme
priorisation merci Antoine
[Musique]
petit monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs d'abord bonne
année à chacun et chacune d'entre vous
pourquoi pourquoi c'est formidable
France 2030 parce que ça met de l'argent
dans le système non non mais il faut
être clair je sais pas si vous avez vu
les dernières études du du ministère et
du du CS notre effort de intérieur de
recherche et développement va descendre
sous les 2,2 % c'estd qu'on est au même
niveau qu'en
1995 à l'époque où les Allemands étaient
à 2,1 ils sont aujourd'hui à plus de 3
et ils sont donnés comme objectif d'être
à 3 et demi les Chinois étaient à
0,695 ils sont quasiment à notre niveau
voire un peu au-dessus aujourd'hui
d'accord donc on est en train de prendre
du retard et lorsque je dis ça c'est pas
juste me tourner vers le public et dire
faut plus d'argent du public
rappelez-vous l'objectif de Lisbonne 3 %
c'était 1 % public 2 % privé aujourd'hui
on est à 22 et même si le public arrivé
par miracle à 1 % on serait loin du
compte on serait à 24 d'accord donc je
pense que c'est il faut être conscient
de ça et quand je dis ça c'est
transpitique he si je peux dire parce
qu'entre 95 et d' aujourd'hui on a eu la
gauche à droite le milieu on a eu tout
le monde mais le résultat est qu'on est
en retard et qu'on est en train de
prendre du retard et donc ce qui est
formidable avec France 2030 c'est quand
même qu'on remet de l'argent dans le
système on en remet pas assez même si
les sommes sont importantes mais on
remet de l'argent dans le système si je
reviens au PEPR le PPR pour le CNRS
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important on joue un rôle essentiel
puisque sur la petite cinquantaine de
PEPR qui ont été lancé le CNRS on pilote
ou copilote quasiment les
3/4s d'accord donc c'est absolument
énorme donc on pilote en particulier on
a on n pas fait la distinction jusqu'à
maintenant vous savez qu'il y a deux
catégories de PEPR il y a les PEPR
exploratoire et les PPR qui s'inscrivent
dans les stratégies d'accélération de
filière industrielle et le CNRS est très
fier de piloter ou copiloter tous les
PPR exploratoires tous d'accord je dis
piloter ou copiloter parce qu'au début
de l'exercice il avait été proposé qu'un
même PPR puisse être piloté
scientifiquement par plusieurs
organismes de recherche ce que nous
avons fait et le paysage français est
tel que il y a peu de sujets qui sont
portés par un seul organisme et donc la
plupart des PEPR sont copilotés par
plusieurs organismes et après pour des
raisons que je qualifierais de
bureaucratique peut-être un peu on nous
a dit non il faut qu'il ait une seule
tête de fil donc on a dit on aa une
seule tête de fil très bien mais la
réalité en parti avec le CEA avec lequel
on travaille beaucoup c'est que il y a
des sujets sur lequels on les copilote à
deux même si un pilote principal prenez
un sujet comme l'énergie ou l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène c'est beaucoup le CEA mais
c'est aussi sensiblement le le CNRS le
bon comme on s'entend très bien avec
François jaces a pas de sujet de ce
côté-là mais le fait est que au
aujourd'hui la plupart des PEPR sont
scientifiquement copilotés par par
plusieurs organismes de recherche c'est
le paysage français et je pense qu'il
faut le considérer comme une richesse et
pas comme une faiblesse la recherche
c'est pas un paysage à la française ça
marche pas comme ça ça marche dans aucun
pays si vous allez en Allemagne vous
avez les max plan les universités la
ELMS labnis les franofers et ils
essayent pas eux de faire des jardins à
la française il
travaill je reviens au PEP
pardon je pense qu'il quelque chose qui
a déjà dit Didier Samuel qui est
extrêmement important c'est que pour la
première fois on a accepté l'idée que
les organismes de recherche étai des
institutions compétentes qui savaient où
étai les bons et les très bons
c'estàdire que quand Didier Deschamp
fait l'équipe de France de foot il fait
pas un appel à candidature pour savoir
où sont les bons joueurs il les connaî
nous c'est pareil d'accord donc dans les
PPR on utilise une partie de l'argent de
à son topd en disant on va financer tel
équipement on va financer telle équipe
et ça c'est un vrai progrès c'est un
vrai gain de temps il faut accepter que
dans un domaine donné c'est une illusion
de penser qu'il y a au fin fond du
Cantal ou de la looser un chercheur dont
jamais personne avait entendu parler et
don va découvrir l'existence via un
appel à candidature d'accord donc il
faut un bon équilibre il faut un bon
équilibre entre les appel à candidature
et le top downown et là je pense que les
P de ce côté-là sont une très bonnes
chose ils ont permis de rééquilibrer les
choses un point important aussi c'est
que les pupè s'enrichissent entre eux
don au sa du CNRS comme on en pilote ou
copilote 36 on a créé une mission au
programmes nationaux mais de façon
générale je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
sujets sur lequels il faut un travail
inter PEPR et c'est c'est une très bonne
chose dernier élément qui enfin dernier
élément un élément supplémentaire pardon
qui n'a pas été souligné c'est que les
PEPR sont aussi dans certains cas des
bons outils pour construire des
relations internationales on l'a fait
par exemple dans le domaine du quantique
donc le quantique pour vous redonner cet
exemple de copilotage on le copilote
entre le CEA le CNRS et INRIA on a monté
un réseau avec le Canada qui est un
sujet un pays important dans le domaine
du quantique voilà donc c'est aussi même
si c'est pas leur objectif premier
quelque chose de de de de tout à fait
positif donc voilà donc les PEPR je
pense c'est vraiment une c'est vraiment
un bon
outil si on regarde malgré tout là
peut-être tout petit reproche qu'on peut
faire au PEPR c'est que on voit que il y
a des thématiques qui sont absentes des
PEPR mais on peut dire c'est la faute
des communautés qui ont pas su ou notre
faute à nous qui n'avons pas su faire
des
propositions tout à fait cohérentes par
exemple dans le domaine des sciences
humaines et sociales il y a très peu de
choses je pense que là il y a un vrai
sujet sur lequel il il y a une réflexion
à voir et peut-être que sur les sciences
humaines et sociales le bon sujet la
bonne façon de faire aurait été d'avoir
voir peut-être pas des P d'accélération
de de filière industrielle mais malgré
tout des PP commandé par l'État qu'il a
un certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels
on pourrait se dire qu'il faut il faut
qu'on qu'on puisse avoir une réflexion
sur le
sujet sur la recherche à risque là
encore c'est de l'argent en plus c'est
formidable la seule choseis vous
rassurer c'est que chaque année le
contribuable donne 3
milliards d'euros au CNRS je voulais
vous rassurer sur le fait qu'on faisait
déjà la recherche à risque on fait pas
de la recherche pépère avec nos 3
milliards d'euros donc c'est non non
mais je pense c'est important de pas
laisser croire que d'un côté on a 3
milliard d'euros on fait de la recherche
pépère on fait juste de l'incrémental et
d'un seul coup on nous donne 40 millions
supplémentaires et enfin on va faire la
recherche à risque je vous rassure nous
faisions de la recherche à risque mais
c'est clair que ce programme va
permettre d'accélérer les choses
maintenant il faut aussi ramener les
choses nous CNRS en 2024 on va avoir 40
millions d'euros sur ce programme ce qui
est formidable ce qui est très bien à
comp pareil avec les 3 milliards de
subventions pour char au service public
donc c'est pas non plus ça qui va
bouleverser la donne on a nous fait le
choix de financer des gros projets donc
des projets aux alentours pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée de de 2 million
et demi à 3 million d'euros ce qui veut
dire qu'on va en financer donc une une
quinzaine avec une notion de risque qui
est qui qui est à définir mais qui peut
être multiple ça peut être un risque
scientifique ça peut risque
technologique ça peut même être un
risque social et c'est tout ça qu'on va
essayer de de financer euh et c'est très
bien d'avoir cet argent là et et je
pense que si on est capable d'être
incitatif là encore avec l'idée que
soyez conscient du fait que 15 projets
pour le CNRS il y a on a à peu près
11000 chercheurs donc là encore on va
pas faire des appel à projet on va
décider de façon top dame en assumant
nos responsabilités que on va financer
tel ou tel projet ou tel ou tel
consortium de de de projet dernier
élément sur les agences après je
répondre à votre
questions
les
agences non non non non alors d'abord il
y a une particularité donc donc le CNRS
s'est vu confier la responsabilité de
l'agence climat biodiversité société
durable comme ça a été dit et vous voyez
que par rapport au SEP agences qui ont
été choisies il y a deux cas
particuliers qui sont celui du CEA un
peu et celui du CNRS beaucoup dans la
mesure où le périmètre de l'agence est
très loin de correspondre périmètre de
du du de l'organisme d'accord donc pour
Didier on peut dire que gros tout tout
l'inerme fait de la santé ENF je je
simplifie un peu mais je suis pas très
loin de la réalité nous bien entendu
tout le CNRS ne fait pas du climat de la
biodiversité des société durable même si
tous les instituts peuvent y contribuer
donc ça c'est une une difficulté pour
nous enfin une caractéristique pour nous
et je crois que c'est important de
rappeler que nos missions premières être
employeur de 32000 personnes piloter ou
copiloter plus de 1000 laboratoires
et copiloter ou piloter plus de 85 % des
infrastructures de recherche de la
feuille de route nationale reste
d'actualité on nous rajoute une 4è
mission qui est importante après je
pense que c'est effectivement un c'est
une fierté pour le CNRS que d'être en
charge de clima biodiversité société
durable qui sont des sujets dont
l'importance n'échappe à
personne après je pense qu'il faut être
c'est quelqueose c'est un objet qui se
met en place et qui va prendre du temps
pour se mettre en place je pense que
l'intérêt
les intérêts tout à fait été décrit par
Didier c'est dire le fait de coordonner
les acteurs et ça je crois que c'est
extrêmement important pour vous donner
une ordidée juste d'un point de vue
académique les acteurs concernés par
climat biodiversité société durable il y
a évidemment beaucoup d'universités
d'écoles mais si je prends juste les
organismes de recherche le CA en fait
l'inerme on fait sur l'aspect santé
environnement l'inrae bien sûr mais
aussi l'IRD le CAD l'IFR le MNHN et et
j'en oublie d'accord donc on va avoir
beaucoup d'acteurs à coordonner si on
réfléchit à des solutions et à un moment
il faut réfléchir bien sûr à les
solutions il faudra y impliquer les
acteurs industriels faudra aussi
impliquer les collectivités
territoriales beaucoup de ministères
lèvent la main donc je pense qu'il faut
que nous soonss ensemble tous très
vigilant sur le fait que nous n'allons
pas rajouter quelques couches de
simplification au système comme on sait
le faire dans notre pays d'accord il
faut être conscient de ça donc donc
potentiellement il y a un vrai intérêt à
ce que l'ensemble des acteurs se
coordonne comment on pratique on va
faire c'est pasenvie dire c'est pas
encore gagné mais on démarre juste donc
soyons soyons peut-être
humble dans les dans les ambitions
donnons-nous une feuille de route pour
les premières années on attend encore
elles vont arriver c'est normal nos
lettes de mission mais mais encore une
fois faisons attention à ne pas croire
que la recherche c'est un jardin la
française et que il y aura un point
d'entrée et tout va se résoudre je pense
que la complexité elle est elle est plus
grande que ça donc c'est potentiellement
tout à fait intéressant pour les raisons
qui avait qu' a évoqué Didier Samuel et
auquel je souscris mais la mise en œuvre
on le sait tous peut peut peut être
source de complexité donc faisons
attention à ça après ces agences sont
autour des grands enjeux sociaux
essentiellement hein mais il y a
évidemment plein de sujets l'a enfin
l'IA est un peu dans le numérique mais
mais le quantique enfin pour pour CIT
que quelques exemples qui ne sont pas
directement couverts par les agences et
on a fait nous une grille qui est
probablement discutable mais qui a entre
les PEPR d'un côté les agences de
l'autre ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que il y a quasiment pas de PEPR
qui sont monoagences hein la plupart des
PP sont multi-agences ce qui montre
d'une certaine façon que des
technologies vont être utilisées dans
dans différents domaines numérique et
santé on est on est un bon exemple juste
parce que Didier Samuel est là mais mais
on peut multiplier des exemples comme ça
donc voilà donc les agences on va
apprendre à les mettre en place et je ne
doute pas qu'on réussisse tous
ensemble merci on va commencer vos
questions tout d'abord en donnant la
parole à notre rapporteur budgétaire
Laurence Garnier
oui merci monsieur le Président merci à
tous les trois pour les éléments que
vous nous avez apportés sur le le le
paysage de la recherche française et la
façon dont il se dessine pour 2024
puisque les annonces du président de la
Ré publuique sont fraîches ell date de
début décembre euh donc un certain
nombre d'éléments de mon intervention se
résront aussi se limiteront à une forme
de wait andc puisqu'on a besoin je pense
que vous aussi d'y voir un peu plus
clair sur la façon dont vont
concrètement se mettre en musique les
annonces du président de la République
euh vous
avez évoquer c'est monsieur le Président
Directeur Général du CNRS le budget
global de la recherche française qui est
effectivement en recul entre 2021 et
2022 à 2,2 % du
PIB vous avez cité nos voisins allemands
qui visent maintenant les 3,5i % les
États-Unis qui sont à près de 3 % donc
il y a de l'argent qui est injecté dans
le système tant mieux chacun ici s'en
réjouit pour autant on est encore loin
du compte et vous avez pointé un des
éléments qui semble faire défaut à la
recherche française c'est
l'investissement du secteur privé euh
est-ce que vous pouvez sur ce point qui
est récurrent par rapport à nos voisins
nous éclairer sur les points de blocage
et sur les les possibilité de bah de de
de débloquer les choses pour faire en
sorte que l'investissement privé vienne
de manière efficace compléter
l'investissement public dont on ne
conteste pas l'effort qui a été fait par
ailleurs au cours des dernières années
euh ça c'est le premier point ensuite
concernant la structuration de la
recherche donc je disais tout à l'heure
le White enc il y a eu beaucoup
d'annonces qui sont encore assez flou
dans leur contour et dans leur mise en
œuvre opérationnelle euh on a différents
niveaux vous l'avez rappelé Monsieur le
Secrétaire général avec à la fois euh du
topd sur les PEPR qui sont très fléchés
euh des appels à projet qui sont
peut-être quand même une forme de de de
de contrainte et de fléchage là aussi
mais plus souple que les PEPR et puis en
en en en bas de l'échelle même s'il y a
pas vraiment d'échelle la recherche à
risque qui là cherche précisément à
inscrire une une forme de confiance
envers les chercheurs de nos de nos
organismes de recherche et à s'inscrire
davantage sur du temps long vous avez
donné le montant Monsieur le Secrétaire
général 500 millions d'euros je crois
qui seront affectés à ces à cette
recherche à risque les curseurs bougent
sur ces différentes manières de de
d'impulser euh nos nos nos équipes de
recherche française euh est-ce que vous
pensez que ce premier pas est suffisant
500 million d'euros c'est grosso modo 1
% des crédits de France 2030 est-ce
qu'il faut poursuivre en ce sens et
voilà quels sont les curseurs pertinents
à poser pour avoir une forme
d'efficacité de de ces de
ces de ces modes de recherche si je peux
dire en complément la encore du travail
à lancer avec le secteur privé donc
voilà ça c'était deux questions sur la
structuration de la recherche vous avez
parlé là aussi monsieur petit de la
question de de de l'efficience des
crédits accordés à la recherche
euh c'est vrai qu'on peut craindre mais
espérons que les choses se mettront en
place le mieux possible que ces
différentes couches de
simplification ne complexifient encore
un système bon voilà mais la complexité
si elle est efficace ne nous pose pas de
problème la question c'est vraiment de
savoir si elle est au service de de
cette efficience de cette efficacité de
la recherche française et on peut
parfois s'interroger mais on va laisser
le temps a temp et voir comment tout ça
se met en place
euh donc structuration de la recherche
différents niveaux appel à projet
fléchage PPR et recherche à risque et
puis je voulais aussi terminer mon
intervention vous interrogeant sur deux
points plus spécifiques le premier sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui a été
peu évoqué dans vos interventions le
président de la République en a parlé
euh lors de son point sur France 2030 à
la mi-décembre je crois que chacun
mesure l'enjeu qui est devant nous sur
cette question je ne crois pas avoir
entendu qu'elle était fléchée au sein
d'une agence plutôt qu'une autre elle
est par essence transversale euh mais
j'aimerais vous entendre sur ce sujet-là
sur les perspectives les points de
blocage et la nécessité peut-être de la
flécher euh en tout cas s'assurer
qu'elle soit
euh prise en compte à la hauteur des les
enjeux qui nous attendent dans les
années à venir et puis un dernier point
qui va s'adresser davantage au président
directeur général du CNRS et de
l'inserme je fais un pas de côté par
rapport à la structuration de la
recherche française vous avez vu que la
presse s'est largement fait l'écho au
cours de ces derniers jours d'un
coronavirus potentiellement mortel qui
arriverait de Chine
euh nous avons lu un certain nombre de
propos de chercheurs notamment du CNRS
euh pointant le fait que le bénéfice
risque de ce type de recherche était
très largement défavorable comme on a la
chance de vous avoir avec nous ce matin
je pense que c'est intéressant aussi
d'avoir votre regard sur ces
éléments voilà ben je vais vous laisser
répondre à ces première séé de questions
et puis après bien sûr
on bien
euh je je ne vu la qualité de nos
rapports avec Monsieur Antoine petit je
vais certainement pas m'inscrire en en
défaut par rapport à son argumentaire je
vais juste lui dire qu'au finfond du
Cantal on a des formidables entreprises
donc non non ne négligeons pas tous les
territoires c'était c'était une boutade
pour vous dire qu'effectivement c'est
tout le paradoxe du plan France 2030 et
et puisque j'ai la chance de parler à à
des représentants de la Nation toute
entière vous dire que je suis bloffé
mais vraiment bloffé dans le cadre de la
mission qui m'est confiée de la
diversité et de la qualité de différents
sujet pas forcément effectivement de
recherche je disais que c'était une
boutade qui viennent de tous les
territoires à la fois de l'hexagone et
ultramarin c'était important de de le
préciser puis qu'une des grandes forces
du plan France 2030 c'est d'avoir révélé
alors plus dans le domaine des
entreprises et de l'industrieir révélé
certains territoires qui étaient
finalement assez inattendu et le Cantal
en fait partie alors maintenant pour
répondre à vos questions plus
directement la question du du secteur
privé est une question effectivement
criante elle vient de de justement un
retard sur la prise de conscience à mon
avis du secteur privé du bouleversement
systémique de la société que nous vivons
et finalement d'une recherche de profit
à court terme pour plein de raisons qui
d'ailleurs en tant qu'ancien
entrepreneur je peux comprendre des
raisons parfois simplement de de survie
ou ou de situation de tension sur des
marchés ou de prix de l'énergie ou de
prix des matières premières faut que les
les les les chefs d'entreprise d'une
façon globale dans leur ordre de
priorité euh servent d'abord l'immédiat
puisque le théorème de dire il y a pas
de futur s'il y a pas de présent est un
théorème normal de de chaque de chaque
chef d'entreprise ceci dit ça fait
partie du jeu mon travail le travail des
organismes de recherche le travail de la
presse également de dire attention il se
passent des choses profondes
fondamentales qui sont évoluées j'ai
connu ça et vous avez connu ça dans
d'autres temps quand par exemple on a vu
l'arrivée des des de l'informatique euh
dans les gestions d'entreprises bah la
France était euh euh au niveau des PME
PMI notamment n'était pas forcément euh
euh très avenant à dire on qu'ils
allaient transformer leur méthode bah là
c'est un peu plus profond c'est
qu'effectivement il faut inventer des
nouveaux process des nouveaux systèmes
euh des nouvelles formulations chimiques
on l'a dit tout à l'heure le le
basculement par exemple de de passer
d'un d'un système où on fabrique les
médicaments à partir de chimie pour
aller vers de la fabrication à partir de
fermentation ou de biologie et ben ce
sont des pas que un certain nombre de
grands groupes et un certain nombre de
PME ETI sont en train de sont en train
de faire mais je pense que cette prise
de conscience elle doit être collective
euh il y a aussi un petit côté nécessité
fait loi à savoir que bah quand on se
retrouve effectivement confronté au
niveau du privé à des situations où on
voit bien ses pars de marché se faire
grignoter par des gens qui qui sont plus
innovants ben il faut se remettre en
selle donc je pense que le processus est
en route nous sommes pas en avance on
est même plutôt en retard mais le
processus est en route en tout cas c'est
mon analyse vu des 3500 lauréas que nous
avons de de France 2030 et à peu près
des 10000 dossiers qu'on a eu analyser
aujourd'hui deuxième chose c'est euh les
500 millions est-ce que c'est assez ou
pas
assez euh 54 milliards est-ce que c'est
assez ou pas assez euh c'est c'est une
question mon notre rôle la France 2030
c'est au niveau de l'état de trouver un
équilibre entre la réalité ce qui peut
être une bonne gestion paèire de famille
de tout le budget des 54 milliards et la
volonté si j'écoutais si j'écoutais je
sais pas la BPI ils vont m'expliquer pas
on met pas assez sur les start-ups si
j'écoute le secteur automobile on dit
qu'on va pas assez vite dans la
transformation du secteur automobile la
réalité c'est que cette transformation
elle va exister sur une génération faut
qu'on arrête de penser que à la fois sur
le plan industriel 40 ans de finalement
déit de transformation de société qui
nous a amené
collectivement j'en partage ma part
comme tout le monde amené collectivement
à penser qu'une France sans industrie
pouvait être
viable va pas se résoudre en 5 ans de la
même manière je pense que il faut il
faut enclencher les phénomènes et les
500 millions sont déjà suffisants pour
en tout cas commencer à avoir des
réflexes de dire et si on pensait plus
loin que la prochaine la prochaine
échéance électorale donc je pense que
que la logique des des exploratoires
c'est vraiment ce projeter loin et et
lever la tête du guidon et commencer à
la à penser à la France de 2050 n'est
pas forcément évident pour tout le monde
j'ai l'occasion souvent sur le terrain
de le constater parce qu'on met les gens
sous pression d'une recherche finalement
qu'on appelle fondamentale mais qu'on
aimerait bien voir tout de suite
appliquer il y a des cycles de
recherches qui sont considérables qui
sont pas que du millefeuille
administratif qui sont juste le temps de
la recherche temps de la recherche n'est
pas forcément le temps politique et et
le temps de la recherche n'est pas
forcément le le le temps de de
l'immédiaté ça y est on a une idée il
faut qu'on trouve une solution alors je
je je pense que cette pression que nous
avons en permanence de dire on est en
retard par rapport à machin par rapport
à truc la qualité quand même de nos
chercheurs en moyenne est remarquable je
pense pas que ça sera les présidents qui
sont là qui vont qui vont se mettre en
défaut elle pourrait être bien meilleure
c'est travail collectif mais je pense
que 500 millions c'est un bon c'est un
bon départ
ensuite vous avez utilisé un mot
intéressant vous avez dit est-ce que
cette complexité peut être efficace moi
j'ai une conviction et je viens du
secteur privé je viens de l'entreprise
j'ai été j'ai été député et ensuite je
me suis engagé effectivement dans cette
mission cette mission de du service
public au service
public je pense qu'il n'y a que la
complexité qui peut être efficace c'est
tout le paradoxe
ça veut dire il n'y a que et la preuve
nous sommes des êtres humains au
complexité extrême et on est plutôt
efficace quand on voit qu'avec quelques
wat le cerveau que nous avons et avec
quelques cellules rassemblé les forces
de vitalité que nous pouvons avoir et je
le dis pas simplement en boutade je dis
que vouloir toujours trop simplifier le
Yaka faucon ne peut pas être une ligne
politique dans des domaines aussi
importants que la science il ne peut pas
et si je parlais tout à l'heure
d'enrichissement et je je rejoins de ce
côtél antoine Petit sur le fait que les
programmes exploratoires doivent être
des associations je vous ai aussi évoqué
le fait que c'est les organisme de
recherche qui travaille avec avec avec
une autorité de tutelle iront plus vers
de
l'interministériel c'est pour vous dire
que cette C l'enrichissement que peut
apporter des perspectives différentes
des approches de recherche différentes
finalement le le hasard d'une équation
découverte dans un institut de
mathématique qui va servir un biologiste
pour résoudre un problème d'ADN et
cetera c'est la complexité qui va être
efficace et ça j'en suis persuadé alors
on tâonne arrêtons de penser que nous
avons la solution et c'est pour ça que
cette année d'exploration va nous
permettre cette année d'expérimentation
pardon va nous permettre justement
d'ajuster les curseurs et de se dire ah
là on va trop loin là on est trop rigide
il faut assouplir et moi je compte
vraiment parce qu'on a une excellente
collaboration entre nous je compte
vraiment sur ces ces échanges pour dire
ça c'est on s'est trompé changeons de
voix et que ce tromper n'a pas être à la
une des journaux ce tromper fait partie
de l'être humain et et on avance dernier
point de votre de votre question est sur
liia lia est au cœur de notre réflexion
on va vers un homonuméris c'estàdire un
homme augmenté et il faut pas l'avoir
comme une terreur il faut juste savoir
que dans quelques années nous dirons
comment on a fait sans la comme on dit
aujourd'hui comment on a fait sans la
télécommunication mobile tout comme on a
dit probablement dans d'autres siècles
comme on a fait avant la maîtrise du
moteur à explosion donc je pense que au
cœur de la révolution industrielle était
la machine qui succédait à l'outil
l'outil ça amélioré la dextérité humaine
la machine ça amplifié la force humaine
bah au cœur de la rvolution industrielle
celle que nous sommes en train de vivre
yia et il faut l'intégrer donc si on en
parle pas c'est parce que c'est une
évidence enfin je dirais si on en parle
pas d'une façon spécifique je pense
queil y a de l'a effectivement dans tous
les secteurs euh que vous avez qu'on a
mentionné alors le pilote dans l'avion
au niveau euh des euh des agences de
programme c'est l'INE ria formellement
parce qu'il a numérique logiciel mais
dans la réalité c'est pas le pilote
c'est c'est là où on pourrait dire il y
a quelques recherches et là antoine va
me pincer il y a quelques recherches
pointues dans l'IA mais il y en a aussi
au CNRS et au et et au CEA et il y en a
aussi au knes parce que vous faites pas
d'IA si on envoie pas pour envoyer des
fusées dans la lune et on fait pas d'IA
si on fait pas de la recherche en santé
de pote donc je pense qu'au cœur c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que ça devient
finalement un mot un peu valise un peu
générique on parlait de la révolution du
numérique on l'a un peu laissé de côté
euh là on est dans espèce de
transformation d'IA et je pense qu'elle
est vraiment au cœur de tous nos de tous
nos systèmes à la fois logiciel et à la
fois demain avec la robotisation
notamment de la société euh à la fois du
matériel donc voilà voilà pourquoi je je
l'avais pas évoqué en tant que
spécifique voilà pardon j'étais un peu
long mais je voulais quand même vous
voulez revenir sur un des un des points
oou Didier
Samuel alors quel peut-être quelques
mots sur le secteur privé et santé euh
je pense que c'est un c'est un vrai
sujet je pense que d'abord euh il y a
plusieurs il y a plusieurs
problématiques d'abord il y a une
ambivalence euh
pendant longtemps même des différents
gouvernements sur les les rapports entre
l'industrie pharmaceutique et et la
recherche avec même il y a eu je dirais
des des ouas considérant que l'industrie
pharmaceutique c'était le diable et je
pense que ça a été négatif d'un côté on
nous demandait de faire des des des
projets publics privés type IHU Rhu et
de l'autre pas parler industrie
pharmaceutique donc ça c'est un c'est un
point je pense qui est en train de
changer et et c'est vrai qu'il faut que
des règles euh et mais et d'indépendance
des deux côtés mais il faut travailler
ensemble encore une fois je l'ai dire en
santé seule l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'est faire du médicament et le
médicament c'est c'est ce qui permet de
soigner les gens donc il faut ça estt
clair l'autre aspect c'est que je pense
que alors je suis moins spécialiste que
Bruno Bonnel mais je pense que et c'est
mon analyse aussi
l'écosystème a été très longtemps
défavorable en terme d'investissement
des industriels ou des investisseurs sur
le soutien et le développement de
produits issus de la recherche en santé
parce que je dirais le développement des
médicaments c'est considéré par beaucoup
d'investisseurs comme quelque chose très
à risque là si je peux revenir sur
recherche à risque un peu casse- figure
pour parler poliment et et donc avec
clairement et c'est une très très grande
différence côté investisseur par rapport
aux USA et ça c'est et on commence
seulement à voir des frémissements mais
c'est c'est encore très lent et on voit
aussi que même dans chose France et à la
suite de Cho France on a vu certaines
grosses industries pharmaceutique et on
voit que ils hésitent encore à à à à à
vraiment s'installer en France à
vraiment investir ils pensent que
l'écosystème est meilleur mais on les je
les sens encore hésitant et de ce
côté-là il y a encore du travail alors
sur le secteur en santé il y a un effort
qui a été fait via les bi clusters qui
est qui est une vraie première approche
mais on voit quand même que les les
pharmas les grosses pharmas elles
investissent mais euh à l'échelle de de
ce qu'elles peuvent faire ça reste quand
même pour moi euh très modéré pour pas
dire plus donc il y a encore un effort
vraiment à faire sur le secteur santé
euh je vais pas revenir sur la
structuration de la recherche je pense
que ça a été dit et le point important
je pense que quand même dans dans tout
ceci c'est le mot coconstruction euh et
c'est arrivé à plutôt qu'avoir des des
qui sont pas dans le bateau et qui
pourrai être freinateurs mettre tout le
monde dans le même bateau et àriver à
travailler ensemble et je pense que moi
je crois à ça mais il faut un certain
volontarisme mais je pense qu'on va y
arriver sur les sur sur l'efficience des
crédits accordés à la recherche je pense
que là il y a le président de la
République le 7 décembre il a parlé du
mot simplification quand il a parlé
simplification il a parlé simplification
de la vie du chercheur ça c'est on est
tous d'accord là-dessus et il a pensé
surtout au niveau des sites c'est-à-dire
relation entre les universités les CHU
pour la santé CHU université unité de
recherche chercheurs médecin et ça on y
travaille mais je pense qu'ai on doit
avoir une simplification au niveau des
procédures de l'État et aussi de tout ce
qu'on demande ça va pour les contrats NR
pour les contrats européens ça va aussi
dans l'évaluation des unités de
recherche par exemple il faut absolument
qu'on arrive à mieux se coordonner entre
HCS et inscerm CNRS dans les au process
d'évaluation tout ceci c'est un travail
qu'on doit faire les PEPR on en a parlé
hein les PEPR sont quand même assez
complexes à monter et je pense qu'on
doit rentrer dans la phase 2 et avoir
des process plus simples et je pense que
il faut les écrire pour que ce soit plus
fluide donc ça c'est c'est le dernier
point alors sur
lia je suis pas le le super spécialiste
et mais bien sûr lia est partout lia est
aussi en santé et je dirais que de façon
plus globale ce que l'on voit c'est que
la recherche médical est de plus en plus
interdisciplinaire que l'on voit aussi
que et c'est ça a été amplifié pendant
le covid on voit les écoles d'ingénieurs
les ingénieurs les mathématiciens les
biostatisticiens des biologistes très
fondamentaux s'intéressai de plus en
plus à la santé et on voit aussi des des
des acteurs de la santé s'intéresser
aussi au monde nouveau numérique les
chirurgiens par exemple qui
euh qui par les chirurgiens par exemple
sont très axés sur tout les tout ce que
peut apporter l'innovation le numérique
en terme de simulation
jumeauumérique programmation d'une
chirurgie simulation d'une chirurgie à
l'avance c'est c'est des éléments qui
sont maintenant qu'il faut qu'on aide et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
travailler entre les différents acteurs
et je pense que c'est les agences aussi
doivent permettre ça et on doit aussi
avoir cet objectif donc plus de
transversalité plus de
transdisciplinarité et c'est c'est c'est
un point essentiel et on a juste pour le
rappeler on a un PPR numérique en santé
avec l'in ria et donc l'ya est bien sûr
un des axes mais c'est bien sûr pas
suffisant et et on
doit et ça doit s'amplifier et on doit
surtout se parler plus entre les acteurs
de l'IA et le monde de la recherche en
santé pour moi alors sur vous avez parlé
aussi du risque lié à la recherche sur
les coronavirus parce qu'en fait ce sont
des coron je pense que vous faites
référence à des coronavirus qui ont été
manipulés génétiquement et qui ont été
donc avec des chercheurs qui ont
travaillé sur des coronavirus et leur
permettant de d'augmenter leur leur
entrée chez l'homme c'est-à-dire donc en
facilitant leur leur entrée dans la
cellule humaine et donc en effet il y a
des il y a des recherches alors là je
dirais à risque de notre façon
c'est qui sont en effet et que l'on doit
surveiller
contrôler alors d'un côté on peut avoir
du plus qui est quand on augmente la
compréhension de l'entrée du virus dans
la cellule humaine c'est aussi une façon
aussi de travailler de l'autre côté sur
comment bloquer l'entrée du virus et ce
qui est d'ailleurs c'est comme ça c'est
ça a été la base des vaccins covid
c'està-d qui ont bloqué la protéine
Spike qui permet d' d'entraîner de
d'entrer dans le dans la cellules
humaines donc mais en effet on doit
faire attention à une dérégulation
totale de la recherche si quand vous
regardez le film openheimer vous
comprenez aussi que la recherche sur le
quantique et la recherche en physique
apporte des des plus et peut apporter
des des actions dangereuses comme la la
création d'une bombe atomique et qui
avec ses conséquences donc c'est c'est
aussi en santé c'est pareil il y a il y
a des il y a des il y a des chercheurs
qui travaillent sur ce qu'on appelle les
gains de fonction des virus et donc en
effet amplifier la pathogénicité des la
force des virus et donc nous on doit
premièrement contrecarer ça surveiller
ça et donc un des rôle de l'incerme et
aussi de la NRS qui qui est une agence
de l'incerme c'est une veille sanitaire
efficiente
et et aussi on doit aussi avoir une
recherche éthique et en tout cas en
France avoir des programmes de recherche
éthique et on a et avec des des comités
de déontologie qui en effet encadrent
aussi la recherche et ne permettent pas
une dérégulation complète surtout dans
un monde où les techniques permettent de
manipuler le gène de de manipuler la RN
et de faire donc c'est en tout cas pour
l'instant il y a pas de d'épidémie à ces
virus mais le fait que des chercheurs
travaillent dessus est une
alerte alors vous êtes nombreux à
vouloir poser des questions donc bien
sûr vous allez le poser on va prendre
toutes les questions je vous invite à à
les noter et je vous invite à respecter
le temps de parole de 3 minutes on a pas
le chronomètre là mais je je je vais
moi-même vérifier et en commençant par
Stéphane
piernoir c'est parti je démarre merci
monsieur le Président merci messieur
pour vos vos exposés je vais évidemment
commencer par me me féliciter du du
financement de de la recherche 54
milliards ça n'est pas rien vous l'avez
dit tous les trois et et et Dieu sait si
les besoins avaient été mis en évidence
lors de la loi de programmation de la
recherche dont nous étions avec Lord
Arcos corapporteur ici au Sénat
euh nous avions entendu lors de ces
auditions une expression plus plus
franche en en direction d'un d'un
financement récurrent un financement
hors appel à projet c'était euh quand
même une constante de la plupart des
auditions que que nous avons eu à à
entendre à ce moment-là j'entends
aujourd'hui un discours un petit peu
différent dans dans vos bouches et puis
donc peut-être que là-dessus vous
pourrez nous nous éclairer un petit peu
je pense que si on a parlé beaucoup de
simplification si le paysage de la
recherche doit pas ressembler à un
jardin français comme vous l'avez dit
Monsieur monsieurel monsieur petit ça
peut pas non plus être une jungle dans
laquelle on se perd au au premier pas et
et là aussi c'est quelque chose qui
avait été mis en évidence les chercheurs
n'en peuvent plus de la succession de
l'accumulation de la superposition des
appels à projets en tout genre vous avez
parlé des l'Agence des agences nationale
de la recherche on a l'impression
d'ailleurs qu'à chaque fois qu'on ne
qu'on qu'on veut faire un grand plan sur
la recherche on rajoute une couche et et
on est loin de la simplification bien
sûr il y a du financement mais la
simplification et la la complexité
efficace que que ma voisine rapporte sur
la recherche appel de ses vœux je pense
qu'à un moment donné va passer par un
regard sur notamment les unités mix de
recherche sur le nombre de tutell aussi
mon ce petit on a souvent évoqué ce ce
sujetlà on est sans doute un pays qui
qui a le nombre de tutelle le nombre
moyen de tutelle le plus élevé en Europe
alors tout cela doit passer vous l'avez
dit aussi par une stratégie alors une
stratégie interministérielle encore
faudrait-il avoir des des ministres pour
se concerter ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui sur l'énergie qui est un P
essentiel de notre industrie à venir euh
une stratégie sur le long terme et on ne
peut pas changer d'avis vous avez dit on
s'inscrit sur le sur le temps long mais
aujourd'hui je j'insiste sur l'énergie
on a pris des décisions il y a moins de
5 ans qui étaient contraire je pense
notamment au nucléaire on avait un beau
programme de recherche qui s'appelait
Astrid sur les réacteurs nucléaires de
de 4e génération il a été décidé
d'arrêter vous savez au combien est
difficile de rattraper le le retard
voire impossible de rattraper un retard
dans le domaine de la recherche il me
reste 20 secondes pour vous dire que
d'abord la stratégie elle pourrait aussi
être européenne et je voudrais vous
entendre sur les partenariats que vous
avez avec les différents organismes de
recherche européen si a une vraie
stratégie qui se construit et enfin
peut-être vous entendre sur la la
mécanique de sélection des 35 des 3500
lauréat sur les 10000 dossiers de
candidature 3 minutes je vous remercie
effectivement merci monsieur le
Président d'abord je voudrais m'associer
effectivement au remerciement pour les
trois interventions qui sont extrêmement
diversifié tant sur le fond que la forme
on va dire que c'est à l'image de la
richesse de la recherche et on est dans
une période où il y a une volonté et un
peu un effet de mode de simplification
de de rapidité moi je je rejoins Bruno
Bonnel la même si la la complexité du
système peut nous laisser perplexe à
certain moment la simplification et la
rapidité ne sont pas synonyme
d'efficacité non plus alors moi j'ai
vraiment une question autour de
finalement qui a une volonté
présidentielle que je partage ça arrive
de temps en temps c'est la clarté dans
le pilotage c'est vrai dans la recherche
mais pas que d'ailleurs mais en ce qui
concerne la recherche moi je voudrais
déjà poser une question sur le domaine
du privé qui est un domaine un peu
particulier parce queon pour le grand
public on pense souvent au crédit impô
recherche et effectivement s'il y a une
augmentation de la LPR il y a encore
beaucoup de retard sur l'objectif de
Lisbonne et notamment la part consacrée
à la recherche dans le PIB et ça vient
évidemment lié à l'inflation au cout de
l'énergie mais aussi à la part manquante
du domaine du privé et si je vous ai
bien entendu sur les objectifs sur le
côté opérationnel de 2030 pour moi il
manque des informations sur dans quelle
mesure les ce qui a été annoncé par le
président de la République notamment à
Toulouse et sur les moyens
supplémentaires dans le domaine du privé
peuvent servir d'effet levier que ce
soit pour les grandes entreprises pour
les entrepris prise moyenne en fonction
des secteurs vous avez parlé de
l'intelligence artificielle mais il y a
le numérique il y a la santé avec les
médicaments il y a évidemment aussi tout
ce qui est lié aux mobilités à la
décarbonation et donc est-ce qu'il y a
une planification qui est prévue un peu
plus précise avec des objectifs et puis
est-ce qu'il y a une volonté de lier ça
avec des laboratoires avec des
universités alors c'est difficile dans
le Cantal mais en fonction du maillage
territorial c'est une première question
deuxième question donc c'est plus pour
les onr alors il se trouve qu'on est la
commission sport donc j'ai bien aimé
l'image d'Antoine petit parce que dans
une équipe de foot pour gagner ils font
des bons joueurs donc il faut les
sélectionner et accessoirement il faut
les former donc ça pose la question des
recrutements et la question de la
formation il faut des il faut des
joueurs qui jouent bien ensemble donc ça
pose la question à nouveau du pilotage
des organismes et puis il faut la
question des centres d'équipement et des
moyens et donc ça pose la question des
moyens au-delà de ça dans le tsunami de
début d'année du président de la
République il reste les annonces et il
reste la même ministre et donc je
voulais vous entendre sur est-ce qu'il y
a une planification de travaux prévus
avec la ministre suite aux annonces du
président de la République sur le lien
université onr ANR sur les questions du
statut chercheur enseignant chercheur
sur la question de l'évaluation et sur
un point particulier je sais qui cœur au
qui est cher au cœur d'Antoine petit et
que je partage qui est l'évaluation à
postériori qui est quelque chose d'assez
innovant pour le coup qui est assez à
risque parce que c'est une agence
tourist que qu'il faut monter je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas ça pose la question
de l'évaluation alors pour reprendre
maintenant la phrase de notre rapporteur
qui disait wait andc moi je suis
d'accord mais just do
ità sans rappeler que nous sommes aussi
la Commission de la Francophonie
mais la
oui merci
beaucoup pour ces interventions
euh je éclairant on va dire les choses
comme ça En tout cas sur sur vos vos
points de vue qui sont pas tous
complètement convergent donc moi j'ai
plusieurs questions je vais revenir sur
l'histoire de la relation publique
privée et des partenariats
euh on manque un peu de règles parce que
dans le partenariat on a aussi un outil
en France qui est le crédit d'impôt
recherche par exemple et donc qui passe
pas par euh par les les euh les
organismes de de recherche ou par le GPI
et France 2030 et en fait on a on a un
problème de lisibilité de la vraie
relation entre le privé et le publicque
en matière de d'innovation et et de
recherche et peut-être qu'il faudrait
commencer à réfléchir à des règles
écrites ce qui permettrait au passage de
traiter les questions éthiques parce que
par exemple quand on parle cancer et
sanopi c'est pas forcément pourquoi
Sanofi pourquoi pas un autre et cetera
donc toutes ces questionsl se posent
légitimement hein et et et il me semble
que par exemple le système américain qui
est pas toujours bon réputé pour pour sa
transparence pour le coup quand on voit
le fonctionnement de du barda on a
l'impression que les choses sont plutôt
assez claires c'estd il y a un objectif
un financement qui finance qu'est-ce
qu'on fait derrière et il y a une
évaluation et donc peut-être que cette
question là pourrait être traitée de
façon un peu plus comment dire
opérationnelle et avec des
conditionnalités parce que
l'accompagnement public vers le privé ça
peut être aussi des conditionnalités et
pour pour le coup on met un peu la
poussière sous le tapis sur ces
sujets-là euh le deuxème la le deuxème
sujet c'est celui du pilotage ENF qui a
été euh plusieurs fois évoqué il y a
vraiment un problème de clarification
parce qu'à force d'avoir des AG des Agen
et des structures qui se rajoute les
unes aux autres et bien ça fait du monde
pour gérer tout ça ça fait
l'administration et quand on parle
d'efficience d'usage des fonds publics
et ben là on peut se poser euh la
question enfin légitimement parce qu'au
bout du bout qu'est-ce qui va finalement
à la recherche dans toutes ces sommes
qui sont qui sont utilisées et donc il y
a un vrai problème de pour pour
clarifier et puis mon mon sujet est
celui aussi de la territorialisation qui
a été évoqué via la lozer et le Cantal
euh mais euh enfin il y a un autre
comment dire on peut voir les choses
autrement que hors du plateau de sa clé
point de salut hors de la PP point de
salut je pense que certes il faut pas
verser dans l'excès euh mais le le
problème d'avoir ces décisions un peu
descendance descendance et concentration
ou surconcentration des équipes et de
considérer que l'excellence et
l'innovation sont toujours au même
endroit et géré par les mêmes personnes
je pense que c'est une vraie
problématique parce que la France des
territoires c'est une réalité et donc la
recherche des territoires c'est aussi
une réalité et que la sélection elle
doit être aussi un peu naturel et pas
uniquement imposé euh et en fait quand
on élimine on a fait oublie le pire du
pire c'est c'est d'ignorer ou de ne pas
regarder et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit vraiment dans dans dans cette
position là pour faire émerger la
recherche qu'il mérite et enfin un
dernier sujet sur les appels à projets
versus les stratégies pilotées je pense
que là on a un petit problème de yatus
entre les les deux parce que les appels
à projet amènent énormément de confusion
dans les stratégies et le pilotage des
stratégies et notamment du point de vue
de ceux qui répondent aux appels à
projet parce que tout tout le monde
n'entend pas l'appel et puis les appels
à projet sont pas toujours pilotés Lord
D'cos qui a été rapporteur de la
LPR merci merci président alors moi tout
d'abord je me félicite des deux
bioclusters qu'on a sur un seul
département le nôtre avec David Ross les
sonnes donc je suis désolée pour le
Cantal mais je dois dire que j'en été
bien évidemment très heureuse ravi aussi
que collectivement nous ayons fait
reculé le rapporteur général lors de la
loi de finances qui voulait quand même
supprimer 100 million d' supplémentaire
au CNRS euh c'était mal connaître le
fonctionnement on peut avoir en effet
bonne trésorerie un fond de roulement
mais quand on voit ce que vous nous avez
développé tous les trois on voit bien
qu'il faut qu'il y ait justement un
petit peu de de réservees quand ce sont
les appels à projet si long comme mes
collègues je suis aussi inquiète sur
l'orchestration entre les agences et les
PEPR j'aimerais bien que vous puissiez
un peu le préciser et puis bien sûr très
heureux de cette mobilisation de la
recherche française en biosanté après
des années de des classements mais
malgré les améliorations l'attractivité
française continue de souffrir beaucoup
des délais de mise en place des essais
cliniques et ensuite de la
transformation en innovation vous en
avez peu parlé j'en ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup travaillé avec philiip Berta
député sur une note de l'opeex sur les
avancées thérapeutiques en oncologie et
c'est encore vraiment vraiment compliqué
en France de de pouvoir transformmer
l'essai et puis comme certains de mes
collègues Cu de la coopération
européenne on est à 5 mois de des
élections ça serait intéressant aussi de
vous entendre
là-dessus minut c'est
parfait pierre zouyas sénateur des
hautes scènes et représentant de la
cor qui un cluster de sens
important merci Monsieur le le Président
vous vous portez Monsieur le Secrétaire
général un un projet de programmation de
la recherche moi ça me va très bien je
suis un un nostalgique du plan gaulien
de de la recherche mais
euh les collègues le savent mais mais
j'aurais aimé que dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation de la recherche euh
nous usussions parlé pas seulement de
budget euh mais aussi euh de programme
je crois que la programmation de la
recherche elle doit être l'objet euh
d'une discussion avec la représentation
parlementaire et au-delà je pense que il
faut absolument que toute la nation soit
associée à la programmation scientifique
il faut un grand débat sur la science et
je regrette que dans le cas de la LPR
nous on pas nous ayons pas eu ce ce
débat scientifique par ailleurs sur la
recherche fondamentale vous l'avez dit
c'est 500 millions
d'euros moi je perçois une une forme de
contradiction entre le côté exploratoire
que que je salue totalement et l'appel à
projet euh je pense que il faut donner
euh aux chercheurs une dimension de
temps long c'est-à-dire 20 30 ans hein
vous parliez de laanr messager la NR
messager c'est 30 ans de recherche et
sur sur un appel à projet faut pas
s'imaginer qu'on va pouvoir innover
ensuite c'est sur le mode de sélection
de vos projets monsieur Monsieur le
Secrétaire général que je voulais vous
interroger vous nous avez dit 10000
dossiers comment vous faites pour
lesctionner pour les sélectionner qui
sont les expert comment vous travaillez
vous aviez indiqué que vous vouliez
peut-être utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle pour les sélectionner je me
permets de vous dire que dans les 10000
dossiers il y en a beaucoup qui sont
conçus avec l'intelligence artificielle
donc il faudrait pas la fin que ça soit
les machines qui jugent les machines ça
c'est le le premier mois et puis par
ailleurs moi j'avais questionné madame
la Première ministre justement sur le
mode de sélection de vos projets qui
m'avait répondu en mars 2023 que vous
utilisiez des fact d'impact de la
bibliométrie euh lche index euh nous
avions commis avec Lord D'cos un rapport
sur l'intégrité scientifique où nous
demandions de façon très forte l'abandon
total de ces technique de biométrie et
vos deux collègues assis à vos droite
l'ont fait de façon extrêmement heureuse
et et je crois que c'est un un exemple à
suivre et je finirai par les sciences
humaines euh vous parlez de révolution
sociétale mais euh il faut absolument
l'accompagner et on voit très bien que
sur l'alimentation et l'agriculture en
ce moment il y a un problème
d'acceptabilité sociale du progrès et
donc si on ninvestit pas dans les
sciences humaines si on ninvestit pas
dans la compréhension de ce qui fait
aujourd'hui blocage dans la possibilité
pour certains d'intégrer le le progrès
on y arrivera pas 3 minutes de monsieur
le
Président merci c'était parfait Mathilde
Olivier
merci je vais faire comme mon collègue
merci monsieur le Président faire comme
mon collègue et mettre aussi mon mon
chrono directement merci pour pour pour
vos interventions vos présentations
c'était très intéressant une première
question dont on a commencé déjà pas mal
parler autour de de ces annonces
présidentielles notamment autour de ce
morcellement administratif qui
affaiblirait la position mondial des
chercheurs le président évoquait aussi
dans son intervention le fait que la
France serait passée du 6e au 9e rang
entre 2005 et 2017 en terme de volume
mais aussi en terme de qualité des des
publications et et qu'il souhaitait donc
réformer transformer le rôle et les
missions des grands organismes nationaux
de de recherche dont le CNRS
l'incerm ici présent quel est votre
regard sur sur ces annonces du président
sur cette planification proposé par le
Président de la République et votre rôle
dans cette planification une autre
annonce présidence autour de ce conseil
présidentiel de la science qui a été
annoncé qui serait chargé d'éclairer
l'exécutif sur les enjeux scientifique
d'avenir et qui fait suite notamment au
rapport gilet qui avait été remis au
ministres en juin 2023 avec l'idée de de
renforcer le rôle de la France comme
leader du du paysage international de la
recherche et de l'innovation qui encore
une fois comment vous comment vous
évaluez la mise en place d'un tel
conseil quel serait votre rôle dans ce
dans ce conseil et et et les liens qu'il
permettrai entre politique et et
scientifique une après deux questions un
petit peu plus
spécifiques pour pour vous Messieurs les
Présidents directeur général de de de
l'inserme et du CNRS sur le CNRS on a eu
le rapport
d'évaluation du
hcrs euh donc donc qui évaluait un peu
les les forces et les faiblesses de
l'organisme qui parlait notamment du du
fort niveau mondial du CNRS mais évaluer
quelques failles notamment sur la
pression administrative important et le
manque de ressources et la complexité
des procédures aussi pour les chercheurs
euh il parlait aussi du rôle du Conseil
d'Administration et euh et et de et d'un
manque de clarté dans les prises de
décision quel retour vous avez euh vous
faites sur ce ce rapport et qu'est-ce
que vous comptez mettre en place pour
travailler sur sur les recommandations
qui ont été faites euh un le plan aussi
que Aline sererme vous vous avez mis en
place sur les fake news qui est je pense
un sujet aussi très important notamment
depuis le covid avec avec avec voilà
tout le le développement des fake news
notamment dans le domaine de la santé
euh euh quel levier vous vous disposez
disposez-vous actuellement pour
encourager les chercheurs à se lancer
dans cette voie notamment de la science
participative et de comment on on inclut
les citoyens dans la dans la création
scientifique dans dans la la la
recherche
scientifique pour pour pour rétablir
ouou renforcer ces liens entre
scientifiques
et et et société civile et citoyen et un
dernier point autour de d'horizon Europe
et donc la France en 2023 et encore il
me semble le
2uxè le deuxème récipendire de de de
d'horizon Europe euh comment vous vous
vous positionnez sur sur les
financements j'ai pas les chiffres en
tête le CNRS et l'inserme en terme de de
de de de d'aide enfin de de projet
horizon Europe que vous avez reçu et
puis on va entrer dans la phase de de
réflexion autour du prochain projet
horizon enfin donc après 2027 sur
horizon Europe et qu'est-ce que quels
sont les les les grandes ligne que vous
souhaitez voir apparaître dans ce projet
dans ce dans ce programme européen qui
est aussi très important en terme de
financement de la recherche
française Bernard
fialer merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs les acteurs moi je vais
travaillé sans chronomètre parce que je
devrais tenir j'ai les mêmes origines
corésiennes que Monsieur ououias par les
mêmes références Gaulistes le plan je
m'inspire peut-être plus de chevinement
mais bon monsieur le Président vous vous
nous avez parlé beaucoup d'agilité
d'efficacité mais quand vous parlez d'un
Comex composé de l'administration
centrale interministérielle j'ais bien
que vous m'expliquiez comment ça peut
fonctionner alors je sais bien que la
complexité et gage d'efficacité mais à
ce moment-là je pense que la France on
est quand même champion du monde et je
vois pas ce qu'on a encore à développer
parce qu'on doit en avoir on doit être
diablement efficace donc tout simplement
est-ce qu'on pvez nous dire quel est
l'apport maintenant du fameux conseil
scientifique qui a été mis en place
auprès du président récemment par
rapport à à ce Comex et et et les
décisions quel est
l'enrichissement de ce comité
scientifique dans cette prise en charge
la deuxième chose c'est quel est avec
France 2030 quel est le gain effectif de
temps pour les chercheurs par rapport
justement à ce qu'il nous décrivent en
permanence et l'épuisement qu'ils ont à
à mettre en
place ces appels la projet est-ce que
est-ce que vous pouvez chiffrer un peu
ce gain de temps et puis enfin je sais
pas si ça relève des des des sciences
humaines est-ce que vous avez des
programmes de recherche sur
l'orientation un petit peu vous nous
dites le retard vient de
l'investissement du privé un petit peu
dans la recherche alors j'ai bien
entendu chef d'entreprise qui dit que un
chef d'entreprise doit veiller à
l'équilibre au charge d'énergie il y a
quand même pas mal de redistribution de
dividende est-ce qu'il y a des
recherches un petit peu pour orienter un
petit peu une partie de ces gains en
cette prolifération de dividendes vers
justement de l'investissement dans la
recherche merci Jacques gropin groserin
pardon merci président merci à vous
trois pour la clarté de vos propos moi
je suis comme Pierre ouulia je crois que
c'est un dispositif qui est très gaulien
et et je m'en félicite j'ai deux
questions vous avez dit Monsieur petit
tout à l'heure vous avez fait référence
au quantal en disant que vous
connaissiez les les les chercheurs
décidément c'est le sparadra qui va
rester ce matin mais les chercheurs sont
connus il a un bon fromage simplement
est-ce que vous avez mis en place des
outils ça c'est pour Monsieur Bonnel des
des outils pour contrôer non pas le
l'efficacité ou bien fonder en tout cas
de des investissements parce que on
pourrait s'imaginer qu'un moment donné
la Cour des comptes même si parfois elle
cache ses rapports pourra être amené à à
pouvoir les contrôler ces financements
qui sont dans est déjà engagé et puis
puisque nous sommes dans la commission
des Affaires culturels en ce qui
concerne la grande fabrique de de
l'image qui doit permettre à la France
de devenir justement leader des
tournages et la production numérique et
je voudrais savoir simplement quel était
l'état d'avancement de ce projet
merci merci et enfin Monique dearco
oui merci euh cette question s'adresse
peut-être plus précisément au secrétaire
général vous avez précisé que près de la
moitié des aides ont déjà utilisé sur
les 54 milliards il a été reproché au
plan 2030 de partir dans tous les sens
de soupoudrer les aides en décembre le
président de la République a adressé un
bilan d'étape parmi les axes
prioritaires le nucléaire a été mis en
avant avez-vous dans le la suite du plan
financement plan 2030 prévu de recadrer
pourrait-on dire les investissements en
donnant la priorité à la recherche la
fusion nucléaire et ceci peut-être
d'autres recherches sur la centré
l'agriculture et quels seront et je
rejoins un petit peu la question de
pierreilia quels seront donc les
critères les modes de sélection des
futurs projets
merci merci je vais vous laisser
répondre évidment il y a plusieurs
sujets qui se recoupent ce qui est
normal donc répartir les réponses qui
commence Bonon bien j'en ai toute une
liste bien bien bien bon d'abord une
précision importante parce que je
voudrais pas qu'on se qu'on se qu'on
qu'on mélange les 500 millions don on a
parlé j'ai on a évoqué 1 % de France
2030 avec la réalité de notre soutien à
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche il est de plus de 10 milliards
sur les 54 milliards mais il faut
recadrer ça puisqu'il comprend à la
foisah on en a parlé les PEPR d'une
façon générale générique pardon mais il
comprend
également le 2 milliards d'investis dans
la formation vous l'avait évoqué
également euh 1 milliard investi dans
les excellences universitaires les
fameux IDEX c'est important donc soyons
bien clair il y a un effort considérable
de France 2030 sur sur ces
problématiques de d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche alors la
sélection vous avez effectivement euh
souligné que il y avait une
contradiction pas une contradiction mais
en fait il y avait une une une une un
flou autour de ces appels à projet les
appels à projet c'est je vous l'ai
expliqu en début de de présentation il
vise à tenir nos objectifs que sont ces
objets tangibles du progrès ça veut dire
quand on dit on veut fabriquer 2
millions de véhicules électriques à
l'horizon 2030 il y a une chaîne
complexe de briques technologiques qu'il
faut satisfaire et c'est ce à quoi
servent ces appels à projet on cherche à
résoudre le problème de bon ben il y a
des problématiques sur les batteries il
y a des problématiques sur les matériaux
de batterie il y a des problématiques
sur les moteurs et les composantes de
tous ces moteurs et électrique et cetera
et cetera il y a des y a des
problématiques de matériaux eux-mêmes
pour alléger par exemple les avions pour
en faire des avion bacarbone donc ces
appels à projet ils ont vraiment comme
objectif de découper en brique
technologique ou en
sousobjectif
c'est C ces objets que nous définissons
globalement comme la réussite de de de
France 2030 alors ça c'est pour vous
expliquer que c'est pas forcément
contradictoire et que ce cette
méthodologie d'appel à projet c'est
finalement celle qui est la plus
équilibrée pour donner une chance à tous
les territoires j'ai entendu le mot
territoire de pouvoir proposer des
solutions et moi je suis assez fier de
vous dire que sur les 3500 lauréats de
France 2030 vous avez 60 % des lauréats
qui sont hors île- de- France vous avez
60 % des lauréats qui sont des TPE PME
ETI qui ne sont pas des grands groupes
et navons que 20 % de grands groupes le
reste étant évidemment des
institutionnels des centres de recherche
sur les crédits globaux donc on a
véritablement généré sur tout notre
territoire une dynamique où on a redonné
un petit peu confiance à la France aux
chercheurs également aux entrepreneurs à
la recherche privée de pouvoir dire on a
des solutions et on veut les les exposer
donc moi je suis pas du tout un
pourfendeur de l'appel à projet alors
est-ce qu'il est est-ce qu'il est
améliorable probablement depuis que je
suis en fonction on est passé de 14 mois
entre le moment où quelqu'un pose un
dossier et le moment où il commence à
toucher son premier chec à de l'ordre de
7 mois c'est de l'argent public on y
fait attention moi je trouve que 7 mois
pour obtenir des millions ça ne me
paraît pas déraisonnable bien au
contraire ça comprend évidemment une
phase assez longue de conventionnement
entre le privé et l'État pour rebondir
sur la question des partenariats chaque
financement chaque subvention fait
l'objet d'un contrat entre la société et
l'État c'est et nous le vérifions nous
le validons avec une procédure de suivi
n avons une équipe d'évaluation interne
composée de 6 personnes
auosgpi qui commencent à travailler pour
être honnête avec vous sur le suivi
pourquoi commence à travailler parce que
on a donné quand même entre 18 et 24
mois de recul à nos dossiers pour
commencer à en voir l'impact vous pouvez
pas donner un chèque à à à à une
entreprise de subvention le jour 1 et et
vérifier si elle a bien exécuté le jour
2 donc il fallait un petit peu de de
temps par rapport à ça la la deuxème
section de bon là j'ai j'ai essayé de
regrouper he des des questions je vais
pas pouvoir
répondre d'une façon littérale à chaque
ligne mais la
deuxè question sur la
gouvernance il y a en fait il y y a
plusieurs gouvernances ne prenez pas mal
ce que je vais dire il y a plusieurs
niveaux de gouvernance dans le SGPI mais
qui sont logiques il y a d'abord un
comité de suivi des investissements
d'avenir qui est composé de six
parlementaires donc TR députés TR
sénateurs et des personnalités
qualifiées bon ce ce comité va être
remis en place puisque la présidente du
comité ayant pris des fonctions qui
étaient en conflit c'était Patricia
Barbizet elle avait pris des fonctions
qui était en conflit avec sa sa son sa
présidence a quitté seront nommés dans
les tous prochains jours un nouveau
président de comité et nous avons à
cette occasion la remise en place de ce
comité ça c'est j'allais dire le conseil
d'administration le conseil de
surveillance interne après la
gouvernance interministérielle j'en suis
le président de de ce fameux Comex et
nous écoutons justement les avis des
différents ministères mais je trouve que
c'est plutôt c'est pas une complexité
nous soumettons à ce Comex des décisions
comme on le ferait à un conseil
d'administration interne à savoir que on
demande un avis et notamment un avis sur
des investissements qui dépassent les 15
millions d'euros pour des entreprises ou
toute opération ça veut dire en clair
quand on dépasse 15 million d'euros on a
on veut avoir
l'accord et il est il est il est
généralement accepté d'un ensemble de de
de de représentants de l'administration
parce qu'encore une fois nous Girons de
l'argent public et ça me paraît
équilibré et il y a des débats à
l'intérieur de ce Comex sur justement
pour rebondir sur votre question les
priorités d'affectation quand vous avez
le représentant du ministère de la
transition écologique qui fait des
observations sur justement la priorité
donné je vous rappelle que 50 % des
budgets de euh de de France 2030 doivent
être consacré à diminuer l'empreunte
carbone et évidemment 100 % ne pas la
dégrader mais les le représentant de la
transition du ministère de la transition
écologique peut être en débat avec un
autre
ministère je sais pas moi l'énergie pour
dire attention équilibrons les
renouvelables par rapport au nucléaire
comme ça a été évoqué et en tout cas
dans les annonces du président de la
République il n'y a eu pour répondre
très clairement à cette question il n a
eu aucune priorité donnée au détriment
d'autres vous faisiez vous évoqueiez la
fusion nucléaire par rapport à d'autres
à d'autres types de de recherche il y a
eu aucun aucune priorité qui est donné
dessus et et nous avons une affectation
budgétaire global qui n'a pas changé au
niveau de de France 2030
sur c'était pas une boutade d'utiliser
lia comme outil quand je dis c'est pas
une boutade c'est de dire tout outil qui
peut nous permettre d'améliorer notre
prise de décision me paraît absolument
utile on utilise les ordinateurs
aujourd'hui on utilise les statistiques
pour prendre des décisions là j'allais
je voulais pas dire que c'était les
machines qui parlaient au machine je
voulais simplement dire que oui nous
avons aujourd'hui énormément de dossiers
et nous sommes une administration de 60
personnes hein le SGPI c'est 70
personnes nous travaillons en relais
avec quatre opérateurs que sont euh la
BPI la caiss des Dépôts et Consignation
l'Agence nationale de recherche et
l'ADEM donc il nous relayent pour
l'exécution et donc pour pour parler
précisément de la mécanique interne ce
sont nos opérateurs qui sont en charge
de la diffusion des appels à projet de
la de de du recueil des dossiers euh de
des candidats de la constitution des
juris qui sont des juris d'experts dans
différents domaines et nous pouvons
apporter là le notre vivier d'experts
quand nous quand nous en avons et de la
sélection de ces dossiers donc ça
pourquoi ben parce qu'il y a une
responsabilité de l'État à déléguer euh
à déléguer cette sélection aux aux aux
structures qui en ont l'expertise la BPI
sur les entreprises a quand même
démontré au cours des 10 ans de passés
qu'elle connaissait quand même bien le
le tissu d'entreprise l'ADEM est en
charge de de l'environnement donc voyz à
peu près comment les répartitions des
appels à projets se font et euh oui moi
je pense que quand j'avais dit utiliser
lias c'est simplement pour dire si c'est
un moyen d'accélérer pour les
bénéficiaires en tout cas une une déjà
une réponse de vous êtes éligible vous
êtes pas éligible parce que
l'éligibilité de France 2030 c'est
correspondre aux objets et avoir une
excellence dans ce qu'on fait mais au
cœur de ça c'est innover et nous avons
eu avec le plan de relance un plan qui a
beaucoup soutenu le capacitaire le
bâtimentaire voir l'infrastructure et ça
ce sont trois piliers dans lesquels
beaucoup de gens mélangent et on reçoit
des dossiers où les gens nous disent on
veut doubler notre ligne de production
industrielle la réponse c'est vous êtes
pas éligible et ça il fallait pas qu'ils
attendent 6 mois pour l'avoir constituer
un dossier et cetera donc moi je pense
que on peut l'utiliser
euh sur sur le je
laisserai je laisserai mes collègues
parler de de de de de la science pure le
Conseil présidentiel et cetera et cetera
sur la relation avec l'Europe sur la
relation avec l'Europe on a des PEPR qui
sont fait fait avec des Européens hein
donc je v pas rentrer dans la liste
exhaustive je pense que ça vous pourrez
plus en parler mais nous nous faisons ça
au au quotidien il y a effectivement un
un travail qui est fait là-dessus les
SHS 100 millions voilà la réponse c'est
100 millions ça veut dire que nous avons
décidé de de débloquer un budget de 100
millions d'euros à destination donc des
des recherches sur les SHS c'est un
début alors pareil on va m'expliquer
c'est pas assez c'est pas en tout cas
c'est 100 millions et et c'est c'est
c'est nouveau il y en avait ça n'était
pas là et ça va nous permettre
effectivement vous avez raison vous avez
prononcé le mot acceptabilité c'est une
des clés c'est une des clés de la
réussite globalement du plan France 2030
mais j'allais dire de la réussite
globalement de notre pays c'est ce dénis
euh de transformation de
société de transformation des processs
qui a duré depuis des dizaines d'années
doit arriver à une à une conclusion
c'est qu'on n pas fait suffisamment de
pédagogie on n' pas suffisamment écouté
on le voit bien aujourd'hui euh c'est
une actualité brûlante euh quand on voit
euh la rédaction de gens en désespérance
comme les les agriculteurs qui
manifestent par rapport à des
réglementations qui sont probablement
très bonne à long terme pour notre pays
sur des interdictions de phytosanitair
et cetera mais qu'en parallèle on est en
décalage sur la recherche je pense
spécifiquement au au phytosanitaires les
phytosanitaires il faut que vous sachiez
on a plus de 150 million d'euros qui
sont engagés dans la recherche de
solutions alternatives simplement je
disais tout à l'heure il y a un temps de
recherche il y a un temps de recherche
et on
peut les bloquer tout de suite pour des
bonnes raisons parce qu'on considère que
c'est très bon pour la santé des des des
Français mais en même temps par proposer
la solution créer des tensions
d'acceptabilité qui ont des qui ont des
qui ont des impacts plus globaux sur un
questionnement sur la science et sachez
qu'on suit de très près on suit de très
près ces questionnements
sur la science ou justement à force de
raccourci donc je viens sur le problème
reviens sur le problème de la complexité
on rentre dans des sciences de plus en
plus complexe et à force de raccourciis
où on essaie de hyper simplifier le fait
que chaque commentateur de plateau et
alternativement un expert du coronavirus
et la semaine suivante un expert des
phytosanitaires et la semaine suivante
un expert sur le spatial fait que moi
les gens nous disent mais mais je
connais cette tête c'est marrant c'est
pique de la Mirandole on est tous des
piqus de la mirandoole moi je peux vous
dire que je ne comprends parfois rien au
truc que je finance mais quand vous
parlez de
quantique tu es là tu es pas là
peut-être que tu es là faut voir si tu
es là enfin au bout d'un moment on dit
mais c'est pas de endroit était là aux
deux endroits voilà non mais ça c'est
pour vous expliquer qu'il y a un moment
donné c'est pour ça que je disais et et
ne confondez pas la complexité
administrative et la complexité des
solutions hein quand je parlais
d'efficacité pour ça que je disais à
force de h simplifieré le fait de Yaka
faucon et vous allez voir ça va bien se
passer bah on arrive à une population
qui ne qui qui ne croit plus en la
science et ça cétait un grand défaut je
voudrais d'ailleurs vous dire un petit
codicile excusez-moi j'en profite pour
vous dire que un des grands soucis qui
est devant nous c'est que quand on
finance pour 2 milliards 2 milliards de
formations nouvelles dans l'hydrogène
dans le nucléaire dans l'environnement
dans le dans les les technologies
spatiales et cetera et que
on narrive pas dans certains cas alors
qu'on a des écoles qui sont flambant
neuv on mange par terre on a du matériel
de pointe avec des professeurs motivés
et qu'on remplit des classes à 40 % on a
quand même une question collective à se
poser sur le message qu'on veut
transmettre sur la science et et je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
quand même sur lequel il faut réagir il
faut arrêter de laisser partir cette
idée que la science c'est mal que la
science ça ça dégrade le futur et il
faut réinstaurer le progrès comme comme
un des axes de fraternité de la France
en disant c'est par là qu'on va arriver
quoi c'est par là qu'on va arriver à
avoir une meilleure santé et cetera
alors sur le dernier sur le dernière ma
dernière réponse c'est sur une question
que vous avez posée
sur et qui qui est intéressante sur les
dividante versus la
red il y a il y a une décision que vous
vous aurez à prendre en tant que
parlementaire un jour moi j'ai eu là
prendre d' autre temps c'est quand on
tient un message au entreprises ont dit
effectivement on veut vous donner plus
de plus de liberté de de développement
et moi j'y crois à ça en tant qu'ancien
entrepreneur je pense qu'il faut qu'une
entreprise elle se développe un peu
comme comme une comme une comme un
organisme vivant dans un environnement
dans un écosystème cohérent euh il
faudra poser la question du partage de
la valeur effectivement parce que les
gains de productivité que fait la
science aujourd'hui grâce au numérique
grâce effectivement à des marchés à
l'explortation qui se développe grâce à
la qualité des innovations que nous
faisons et bien vont être considérables
et là je pense notamment à l'impact de
l'IA sur beaucoup de domaines et à
l'automatisation en général quand je dis
l'IA vous avez compris que je je
l'entendais logiciel et matériel bah les
gains de productivité il va falloir
s'interroger sur comment on va les
partager voilà donc c'est pas une
décision que l'entrepreneur va faire
aujourd'hui il est dans des règles tant
qu'il aura ou vra les guillemets le
droit ou pas le droit de faire ça il
suivra ses règles euh il y aura une
vraie question à un moment donné à se
poser là-dessus elle est elle est en
tout cas pas au SGPI elle est pas dans
les organises de recherche je pense euh
ou peut-être tu as des idées là-dessus
mais elle est pas dans le Cantal mais
euh parce que c'est un Paris qu'on a
fait ave que Antoine de savoir combien
quel est celui qui dirait le plus de
fois le mot Cantal c'est ça on doit vous
avouer maintenant le voilà vous avez
gagné mais mais plus sérieusement je
pense que cette question quand je vous
parlais d'une transformation sociétale
cette question tout comme il y a eu des
règles de de d'économie libérale ou
d'économie tout court qui ont été amené
par la machine quand on a transformé le
finance par tâche en financement par
salariat qu' transformer la fabrication
artisanale en fabrication industrielle
et bien il y aura les mêmes questions à
se poser sur les années à venir sur
quels impacts macroéconomiques auront
ces révolutions de la science et et ce
bouleversement sociétal ça que dividende
contre RD c'est une question qui se
règlera à mon avis par l'établissement
futur de nouvelles règles parce que si
on compte sur l'entrepreneur individuel
pour dire pour faire ses arbitrages il y
aura autant de décision
que qu'il y aura d'entrepreneurs et je
pense pas qu'on aura l'équation en
faisant en délégant simplement la
responsabilité au privés de le faire il
y aura un encadrement un jour à penser
dans ce domaine voilà moi j'ai répondu à
mes questions à vous messieurs à nous
j'espère qu'on a plus de 3 minutes
oness madame Olivier a rappelé que le
CNS avait été évalué par le le au comité
le Haut Conseil à l'évaluation de la
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur
par un jury qui était exclusivement
international donc ça nous a changé un
peu nos trucs franco-français présidé
par Martin veterli président de le PFL à
Lausanne et la conclusion du comité
c'est il a écrit le comité d'évaluation
est heureux de saluer la reconnaissance
au plus haut niveau mondial de la
production scientifique du
CNRS puisque j'ai compris qu'il fallait
parler anglais dans cette commission
j'ai envie de rajouter what
else alors et mais je trouve non non
pour être sérieux je trouve qu'on passe
beaucoup de temps je parle pas de la
réunion que nous avons aujourd'hui je
trouve qu'on passe beaucoup de temps à
courir comme des canards sans tête
pendant que les Chinois les Allemands
travaillent c'est quoi l'objectif qu'on
se donne qu'est-ce qu'on veut de plus je
veux bien qu'on dise il y a trop a trop
de tutelle aux UMR peut-être sûrement si
demain il y a qu'une tutelle qu'est-ce
qu'on aura changé dans la production de
la recherche française
rien d'accord rien donc est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas quand on fait quelque chose
de poser la question de quel est le gain
qu'on cherche à obtenir si le gain c'est
on va avoir un jardin à la française
c'est est formidable les étrangers s'en
foutent complètement la production
scientifique ne va pas s'améliorer
d'accord et je pense qu'on a un sujet
aujourd'hui on a un sujet c'est celui de
l'attractivité l'attractivité vis-à-vis
des jeunes ça a été mentionné par Bruno
Donel l'attractivité vis-à-vis de
l'étranger parce qu'on a une compétition
internationale c'est comme en foot pour
attirer les talents et les garder
d'accord et on a l'attractivité du privé
c'est ça les vrais sujets le reste de
savoir est-ce qu'on fait des agences un
conseil scientifique des UMR à droite
des UMR à gauche des machins on s'en
fout c'est pas le sujet
d'accord mais je trouve qu'on a une
capacité à passer notre temps à se
regarder le nombril la recherche aller
internationale pourquoi la
territorialisation de la recherche c'est
bien joli mais en première division en
foot je cette image on a 20 clubs ça
veut dire qu'on a pas un club dans tous
les département et au niveau
international c'est la même chose est-ce
qu'on compte au niveau international
c'est ça qui est important c'est pas de
savoir si si on compte au niveau local
au niveau local je pense que
l'attractivité un sujet majeur qu'on ne
traite pas qu'on ne traite pas après si
je redescends un niveau plus bas
d'accord public privé je pense c'est un
vrai sujet moi je regrette qu'il soit
impossible dans ce pays d'avoir un débat
serein sur le crédit imp pour recherche
c'est juste impossible c'est impossible
avec mes chercheurs qui me disent mais
tu tromes pas certains de mes chercheurs
qui me ditent mais tu te rends pas
compte c'estes 6 milliards de manque à
gagner et je leur dis mais est-ce que
vous êtes naïf pour penser que même si
l'état récupère 6 milliards de plus il
va nous les donner vousê vous êtes des
vous êtes des des enfants de cœur
d'accord et donc c'est donc on peut pas
avoir ce ce dialogue avec on peut pas
non plus avoir ce dialogue avec Mercy
parce que le fait de dire peut-être tout
est pas tout n'est pas parfait et
quelque chose qui donc est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas juste avoir un débat parce
que le patron qui veut pas investir plus
dans l' RD on va pas l'obliger investir
il faut essayer de comprendre pourquoi
il investit pas plus et qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire pour qu'il investisse
plus on a fait une proposition qui est
qui est comportée par un certain nombre
de gens dont la NRT d' c'est de dire
est-ce qu'on pas trouver un système pour
financer
cofinancer les laboratoires communs
entre le public et le privé le public
mettrait x le privé mettrait y et l'État
abondrait d'accord donc c'est pas tout à
fait comme le créd pour recherche parce
que ça va directement au laboratoire
commun je dis pas que c'est la solution
miracle mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que on ne peut faire que le constat que
la partie privée de la RD est
insuffisante il faut qu'on trouve des
dispositifs avec les acteurs du privé ce
sera jamais contre eux ça c'est un point
qui me semble essentiel sur le soutien
de
base pour dire sur ce qui disit le
sénateur piéoir oui oui bien sûr
l'équilibre n'est pas bon aujourd'hui
entre le soutien de base et les appels à
projet et ça il faut retrouver un bon
équilibre je n'utilise pas le mot
récurrent parce que dans le pour les
command des mortels récurrent c'est le
truc que vous avez automatiquement quoi
qu'il arrive le soutien de base qu'on
distribu au laboratoire on le fait sur
la base des évaluations scientifiques
c'est pas juste vous avez eu 100 l'année
précédente donc on vous donne 100 cette
année c'est on regarde comment la
situation l'évaluation scientifique mais
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a
pas un bon équilibre entre les appels à
projet les souti
tous les pays tous les grands pays
scientifiques ont des agences de
financement des agences de moyen donc il
s'agit pas du tout de dire il faut
supprimer la NR il faut qu'on ait une
ANR il faut qu'on ait une ANR avec
suffisamment de budget pour que les taux
d'acceptation soient importants mais
dans le même temps il faut que on ait un
soutien de base une capacité c'est vrai
pour les organismes c'est vrai pour les
universités une capacité à financer une
partie des recherches en topd là encore
de façon directe et ça je crois
qu'aujourd'hui l'équilibre n'y est pas
ce qui était prévu c'est un équilibre
avec les en préciputes que ça soit les
préciputes des programmes de France 2030
qui ou les préciputes de l'ANR
peut-êtreil faudra être plus explicite
parce que les préciputes sont encore vu
par les chercheurs à les chercheuses
comme entre guillemets on leur pique de
l'argent alors qu'en fait c'est juste
une façon de répartir l'argent mais ça
je je pense que c'est un sujet qui est
qui est absolument absolument majeur
donc voilà je pense que je pense qu'il
faut qu'on il me semble que on dans C
toutes les réflexions qu'on peut avoir
on souffre de notre incapacité à nous
donner des objectifs c'est-à-dire dire
que les agences très bien mais c'est
quoi l'objectif qu'est-ce qui fera que
dans un an dans 2 ans dans 3 ans on sera
content on aura avancé la simplification
c'est le bon exemple qui est contre la
simplification personne très bien motion
adoptée à l'unanimité d'accord et après
on fait quoi et ça veut dire quoi la
simplification tout le monde est
évidemment d'accord pour simplifier
est-ce qu'on peut pas se donner un
certain nombre d'indicateurs qui peuvent
être très pragmatique hein c'est not le
temps qu'on va mettre pour recruter un
CDD c'est le temps qu'on va mettre pour
payer un fournisseur c'est le temps de
rembourser une mission il y a un certain
nombre de choses sinon on fait la
théorie d'accord et très franchement
onance pas beaucoup ça fait 20 ans qu'on
nous parle des relations entre les
universités les organismes de recherche
je dis pas que tout est parfait je dis
juste qu'encore une fois pendant qu'on
réfléchit à ça les Allemands et les
Chinois
[Musique]
travaillent
merci un certain nombre de questions
donc tout d'abord sur le financement
long et la loi de programmation de la
recherche je pense que il y a en effet
il y a de d'abord on avait au départ des
questions sur le France 2030 et et donc
ce que ça a apporté mais pour moi ça
doit pas
exclure le financement long et en effet
une vraie réflexion sur comment on
soutient les les organismes de recherche
et comment on finance et derrière tout
ceci il y a premièrement la possibilité
pour les organismes d'avoir je dirais
une marge de manœuvre pour définir la
stratégie et pas seulement consommer
tout l'argent uniquement sur les
salaires et sur le et sur l'immobilier
il est extrêmement important aussi qu'il
a une réflexion et qui soit renforcé et
la LPR est un début mais je pense que on
doit renforcer sur l'aspect attractivité
des carrières et des chercheurs il faut
si si la recherche française elle a elle
a baissé ce qui est le ce qui est vrai
c'est aussi parce que on a sous-investi
en recherche tant au niveau des moyens
qu'on a attribué à la recherche mais
aussi aussi au niveau de la valorisation
des carrières des chercheurs on a
demandé aux chercheurs des dossiers
extrêmement complexe avec des taux de
sélection extrêmement forts et des
salaires qui sont extrêmement bas dans
l'échelle de la société si on veut les
meilleurs on doit les payer et donc il
faut et donc de ce côté-là on doit
travailler à améliorer l'attractivité
des carrières plus de promotion CRDR des
salaires pour les CR à plus haut niveau
et et c'est absolument essentiel si on
veut faire revenir au garder les jeunes
il faut que le métier de la recherche
soit attractif et ça c'est vrai aussi
dans les hôpitaux et secteur que je
connais très bien donc il faut aussi un
investissement long et ça je pense que
c'est absolument essentiel parce qu'en
effet on peut pas fonctionner uniquement
par à coup et donc il est important
aussi d'avoir une stratégie
d'investissement de la recherche et de
comprendre aussi que la recherche il y a
un temps long euh et c'est important
pour les politiques de comprendre que le
retour sur investissement n'est pas
immédiat et ça c'est quelque chose c'est
différent de l'innovation il y a il y a
besoin euh on l'a dit tout à l'heure
pour la RN messager pour d'autres ça
prend 20 30 ans avant que ça porte ses
fruits mais quand ça porte ses fruits
c'est parce qu'on a investit à 20 ans et
ça c'est absolument essentiel et c'est
quelque chose qu'au plan je dirais macro
et et au plan des politiques on doit
comprendre et l' et si on veut revenir
dans la cour des grands et bien il faut
aussi que on mette les moyens pour être
dans la cour des grands donc ça c'est et
alors derrière aussi l'évaluation et
vous avez évoqué le la problématique de
l'évaluation l'évaluation ça ne fait pas
peur l'évaluation elle est absolument
nécessaire parce qu'en effet c'est se
remettre en question c'est redéfinir des
stratégies c'est se poser les bonnes
questions voir ce qui va pas pouvoir
aussi corriger donc ce qui va pas et
aussi mettre l'accent sur ce qui va bien
donc c'est mais ça doit aussi ne pas
être toutes les 5 minutes donc il doit y
avoir un temps d'évaluation qui doit
être respecté entre les les actions mais
pour les agences qui viennent de se
mettre en place en effet je pense que
c'est bien comme c'est vraiment très
nouveau c'est bien d'avoir un point
d'étape dans un an pour pour voir ce qui
va ce qui va pas est ce qu'on doit
corriger pour remettre pour remettre
l'axe je pense que de toute façon un des
points majeurs aussi et pour pour le
gouvernement et pour les politiques
c'est vraiment est-ce qu'on veut de la
recherche de qualité quelle est la place
de la recherche dans la société
qu'est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on veut
attirer de nouveau les les meilleurs
chercheurs est-ce qu'on est capable de
faire revenir des chercheurs français
qui sont partis à l'étranger est-ce
qu'on est capable d'attirer des
chercheurs étrangers et ça c'est la
compétitivité internationale
euh sur le l'aspect gouvernement et
recherche ben on a besoin de stabilité
aussi pour pouvoir mener à bien les
projets et pas de partir dans
différentes directions tous les 6 mois
et ça je pense que c'est c'est un point
important sur la partie privée vous avez
évoqué madame la sénatrice le barda et
aussi le fait que un un industriel seul
avait été choisi dans le biocluster
pareil cancer alors premièrement c'est
c'est venu d'abord au départ des de de
c'est pas venu de de nous hein donc
c'est c'est eux qui ont choisi
d'investir dans dans cet axe mais c'est
à l'époque j'étais doyen de faculté et
c'était dans mon domaine de secteur
puisque Gustave rousi est dans mon était
dans mon secteur et j'avais attiré
l'attention en effet il faut pas que ce
soit bloquant pour que d'autres
industriels viennent et en effet quelque
part dans la toute la réflexion qu'on
doit avoir sur les bioclusters c'est en
effet une ouverture et pas en effet
qu'un seul industriel mais une ouverture
mais ce qu'on a besoin clairement c'est
beaucoup plus d'investissement venant du
privé dans le domaine de de de la
recherche et pour moi dans le domaine de
la recherche en santé alors sur les
territoires je vais pas revenir sur le
mais dire quand même premièrement tout
le monde peut pas tout faire les
territoires c'est important et on
travaille avec les universités mais le
point c'est de définir aussi les axes
forts un certains certains CHU ou
certaines UMR ne pevent ou certaines
universités ne peuvent pas tout faire et
on doit définir avec eux les axefors et
les soutenir et on doit aussi faire
opérer je dirais dans une stratégie au
niveau national c'est à la fois soutenir
des axesforts et les renforcer S sont
compétitifs s'ils sont pas compétitifs
on peut être amené à les abandonner et
aussi soutenir les axes émergents et les
chercheurs émergents qui vont être les
les les les les stars de demain et ça
c'est aussi notre responsabilité où
qu'il soit de de pouvoir les les
accompagner euh pour la partie médecine
sur les délais de mise en place des
essais cliniques alors clairement euh il
y a les essais cliniques à promotion
industrielle qui vont très vite parce
que les industriels mettent le paquet
pour mettre en place les essais
cliniques et de ce côté-là aussi à la
place de la France dans les ESS
cliniques à promotion industrielle et
c'est important d'avoir des k opinion
leader qui soient capable d'être de
d'être présent et que les services
médicaux soi puissent inclure des
patients dans les essais cliniques de de
très haut niveau internationaux à
promotion industrielle mais il a la
question des essais cliniques à
promotion académique et en effet je
pense que que là clairement on doit
clairement améliorer le fonctionnement
du PHRC on doit améliorer raccourcir les
délais mettre plus de moyens en manpower
sur les techniciens d'études cliniqu les
chefs de projet pour que les essais à
promotion académique soit soit efficace
et aussi être pertinent c'est-à-dire
quel est l'impact aussi que ce qu'un
essai clinique va avoir aussi sur la
compétition mondiale et ça c'est souci
de la stratégie c'est-à-dire pas mettre
des essai cliniques sans sans réflexion
mais aussi avoir une une stratégie un
objectif et l'objectif c'est pas d'être
compétitif au niveau local c'est d'être
compétitif au niveau international
d'être capable de publier dans les
meilleures revues et de sa discipline ou
du général type New England ou land 7 et
c'est ça l'axe que doivent avoir les
essais cliniques académiques mais pour
ça on doit mettre les moyens dessus
alors sur l'Europe je pense que c'est un
c'est un c'est un axe il y a deux
plusieurs axes premièrement sur les
grands programmes je pense qu'on doit
aussi nous avec l'aide aussi des des
autorités être présent pour essayer
d'influer sur les programmes que l'on
souhaite c'est-à-dire donc être présent
à Bruxelles pour
justement soutenir les axes que l'on
souhaite dans les dans les futurs
horizon Europe 3 je sais pas comment il
s'appellera parce que c'est en effet il
faut que la France puisse faire parler
sa voix et aussi faire soutenir les axes
qu' qu'elle souhait soutenir donc ça
c'est un premier point donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut être présent localement et
faire aussi du lobbying pour que du
lobbying efficace pour soutenir les axes
qui qui qui qui nous paraissent
prioritaires donc ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point c'est c'est les la
capacité à aller à l'international pour
les chercheurs je pense que on a mis en
place des outils euh il y a les
programmes
àdesr pour et des pour l'Europe je pense
que là il faut qu'on réunisse nos forces
euh CNRS ins université CHU même pour
avoir des pôles Europe où on va
premièrement faire du proactif vis-à-vis
des chercheurs c'est-à-dire repérer les
chercheurs qui ont une capacité à
aller à la compétition sur horizon
Europe ou sur des ERC ou sur des
maricues mais aussi les aider à les
accompagner via ces pôle Europe à monter
les projets et ensuite à les gérer parce
que on dit que la France est complexe
mais pour ceux qui ont déjà géré des
projets européens c'est pas si simple et
donc la gestion des projets européens
nécessite une aide logistique importante
et donc ça de ce côté-là on doit
vraiment être proactif on doit aussi
c'est depuis que je suis arrivé à
linerme je suis allé dans en Allemagne
je suis allé en Autriche je suis allé en
Espagne j'ai rencontré aussi mes
homologues et en effet on doit renouer
je pense et renforcer les liens entre
les agences et aussi certaines grosses
universités européennes et je pense que
peut-être ce ce point été d'une part un
peu je dirais sous-traité il y a eu
aussi en senté l'effet covid qui a été
un un je dirais une sorte de coupure
quand même pendant 2 ans qui a été très
néfaste mais je m'attache en tout cas à
mon niveau à à à relancer ces ces
coopérations qui sont j'étais membre de
quand dans une autre vie d'association
scientifique européenne et j'ai toujours
cru à ça à l'Europe j'ai dirigé un
journal européen et j'étais j'ai
toujours J a toujours cru donc ça c'est
alors sur le conseil de la science je
vais juste dire je pense que ce qui est
important vis-à-vis de de de l'apport au
présid président de la République c'est
aussi de faire de rappeler au président
et de le je sais qu'il le sait mais
l'importance de la recherche ce qu'est
la recherche plus et le temps long que
nécessite la recherche et l'importance
de la recherche pour et de
l'investissement en recherche pour la
France quels que soient les je dirais
les axes santé numérique SHS ou autre et
je pense que c'est en ça que ça que
j'espère que ce conseil aidera enfin
pour finir sur les fake news et la santé
c'est c'est un vrai sujet que l'Inserm
s'en a emparé même avant mon arrivée
puisque il y a eu un un livre sur les
fake news écrit par l'incerme il y a
l'incerme a mis en place une chaîne qui
s'appelle canal dtox où ils ont mobilisé
une centaine de chercheurs capables de
répondre à des fausses informations mais
derrière ça il y a de façon plus
générale il y a la capacité aussi à à
communiquer auprès du public euh et à
faire comprendre l'importance de la
science et de la recherche mais il faut
aussi que le qu'on qu'on combatte aussi
les les chercheurs ou les
pseudochercheurs qui qui répandent des
je dirais des informations fausses fake
ou complotiste ou ou équivalent qui sont
extrêmement nuisibles et il faut donc
qu'on soit prêt à répondre qu'on soit
proactif mais il il faut aussi qu'on
arrive à communiquer et à faire
comprendre au public le le rôle de la
science parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on
pense le lien n'est pas forcément
évident entre recherche et progrès et
recherche et impact pour la vie des gens
et en en société en santé les gens ont
du mal à comprendre que les médicament
qui arrivent sont le fruit de recherches
qui qui qui ont été faites en amont et
et ça pour et l'importance de de de de
l'apport de la science et de la
recherche c'est sur l'impact de la vie
et sur l'impact de la santé et de la
qualité de la santé qu'on qu'on donne
c'est un travail de fond que l'on doit
faire donc un répondre au fake news mais
aussi communiquer auprès du public de la
importance de la science et faire
apprécier la science et c'est aussi
important dans la formation dans ma vie
précédente de doyen je pense que c'est
important aussi que les les jeunes
comprennent l'importance de la recherche
et et aussi dans les études dans la
formation comprendre ce que ce que c'est
la science et peut-être qu'il faut
insister plus en terme de formation sur
l'apport de la science l'apport de de la
formation sur les progrès qui pour la
société voilà en gros ce que je peux
répondre j'espère que j'ai pas trop
oublié de choses deux petits mots
complémentaires d'Antoine REM rap une
remarque sur mon domaine d'origine les
algorithmes deep learning
l'apprentissage profond qui sont à la
base de tous les progrès de Lia
aujourd'hui ils datent de la fin des
années 80 d' il y a 35 ans d'accord donc
vous les avez découvert probablement il
y a 6 mois ou 3 ans mais c'est 35 ans
d'accord donc il faut être conscient de
ça sur l' on en a parlé mais moi je je
je c'est un pays c'est un domaine dans
lequel il y a une compétition
international absolument exacerbé pour
attirer là encore les les meilleurs
talents moi je crois beaucoup au fait ça
a déjà été dit mais je là-dessus qu'on
va pas être un grand pays de l'IA en
général mais on va être on peut être bon
on doit être bon sur Ia et X X pouvant
être la santé pouvant être
l'environnement pouvant être l'énergie
et si je regarde les start-ups qui sont
issus du CNRS il y en a quand même une
centaine par an il y en a un grand
nombre qui effectivement associe des
compétences en Y a et et et et des
compétences dans un autre domaine
applicatif et je crois que là il y a un
vrai un vrai enjeu sur l'Europe juste
pour répondre à Madame Olivier les deux
organismes bénéficiaires les plus
bénéficiaires des programmes cadres
européens si je regarde 2020 qui s'est
écoulé donc on a un bilan c'est de très
loin le CNRS avec 1 milliard 2 le
deuxème c'est le CEA avec 700 millions
le 3è c'est franer je vous garantis pas
tout à fait les chiffres à diaines prê
mais avec 680 et le 4è c'est Max plan
avec 640 donc il y a et alors c'est en
particulier il est à notre taille ça
faut pas s'en cacher mais pas seulement
d'accord donc on a au niveau français
des programmes des des résultats à
l'Europe qui sont très hétérogènes selon
les acteurs ça rejoint des sujets qu'on
a déjà abordé et peut-êtreut si veiller
à ce que les acteurs les moins
performants le le soient plus mais je
crois qu'on sera vraiment d'accord avec
avec pour dire qu'il y a pas d'avenir à
la recherche en dehors de l'Europe c'est
c'est très très clairement à ce
niveau-là qu'il faut réfléchir à certain
nombre de choses et c'est pour ça qu'on
va plaider comme on le fait pour qu'il y
ait une augmentation significative du
prochain programme cadre européen et je
pense que si on veut compter c'est si on
veut jouer en première division si on
veut être champion de 3e division alors
faisons de la recherche dans tous les
territoires restons franco-français
c'est formidable si ou pas si notre
ambition c'est de compter au niveau
international alors l'Europe à mon avis
est un échelan absolument
indispensable juste une un mot de
conclusion pour vous expliquer et
j'espère vous avoir convaincu de
l'importance de la participation de
l'État à cette transformation sociétale
là on l' vit sous l'angle recherche on
pourrait avoir ou ici ou dans de
commission vous rapportez ce qu'on fait
dans le domaine industriel et et et est
dans le domaine effectivement de la
création de de valeur à la fois en
emploi et en et en produit mais je je
voulais quand même pas quitter cette
salle sans vous dire que euh sans cette
accélération apportée par l'État par les
moyens de l'État euh nous n'aaurions pas
euh nous n'ons pas la bonne vitesse pas
que tant que nous ayons pris du retard
c'est juste que le temps s'accélère et
je pense que au-delà de France 2030 si
on a beaucoup parlé de planification euh
au-delà de France 2030 il y aura de
toute façon une réflexion à avoir dans
les dans les mois ou les années qui
viennent pour savoir comment on va
continuer continuer cette effort le plus
grave serait à mon avis de faire du stop
and go et évidemment je me ferai
probablement l'avocat d'une réflexion
sur comment on amplifie encore tous ces
efforts parce que au bout de la route ce
sont des efforts d'investissement ce ne
sont pas des efforts juste de dépenses
et les différents rapports qui sortent
sur le retour pour l'État sont sont
plutôt positifs donc je p pense qu'on
aura l'occasion et vous aurez
certainement l'occasion dans des séances
de d'en débattre au niveau budgétaire de
la réflexion de savoir dans quelle
direction et comment est-ce qu'on
continue cet effort de de l'État dans le
dans le futur merci à vous tous merci
Monsieur pour ces réponses très précise
il est important pour notre commission
et nous essayons de le faire très
régulièrement de de vous suivre dans vos
travaux la la recherche n'est
malheureusement pas un élément central
du débat public où où devient quand il y
a une difficulté et et nous nous avons à
cœur justement de vous suivre non pas au
quotidien mais de manière très régulière
pour bien comprendre comment
l'écosystème qui est complexe mais qui
est quand même efficace comment cet
écosystème fonctionne et quels sont les
les enjeux auxquels il est confronté
comment nous nous pouvons dans nos
décisions vous accompagner utilement
merci beaucoup merci à
vous